[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey you guys
she thought she pressed the wrong button
i did well i did press the wrong button
that was actually it was actually the
outro she put [ __ ] second sexy
[ __ ] hats on the damn title so uh
people in there go oh wait this [ __ ]
could wait here we go we gotta see the
sexy hat you guys know what this is this
hat well
i can i always try to like think of a
name for it it's like i'll i can change
it later but i just need something to
come up with and it's like you you
brought those in and i said well i can't
call it [ __ ] hatties that was the
first thing thought
and i'm like no cause then it'll get
demonetized
so i got to monetize just for you saying
that
no because we've said that lots of times
they don't get democratized but i pull
up on my [ __ ] mind this is my sexual
police manhattan yeah if i can pull up
on my bike with this hat on cyrus flash
and start handing out citations to
anybody who's not having sex you're not
having sex [ __ ] that's it and then
you know if if anybody looks anti-sexual
they got to lock them up
lock them up take it take them to bot to
[ __ ] bondage prison
bondage prison i kind of like the sound
of that um so can your sexual policemen
lights be hot pink they're whatever
color is like in style at that time
i got those multi-colored [ __ ]
leds can you also have a disco ball it's
got that too like in your
two disco balls that hang down for the
back near the back tire [ __ ] shining
on the ground they're bike nuts now
trucks have trucks let's say so they got
bike nuts
[Laughter]
are they bigger or smaller than truck
nuts
bigger
of course that's what i think of course
yeah they're real disco balls
yeah
wouldn't it be weird if oh now i just
had like a really [ __ ] up uh mental
picture of somebody that
glued little shards of mirrors all over
their testicles like to have like little
materials she's daring me she's trying
to get me to do that i'm not now i'm
almost kind of i'm not going to google
it
maybe i will i'm sure somebody in the
world has done that yeah you know so do
roll call who's in here at some point
they're coming in dj maniac said that uh
him and elsa are meeting up in brooklyn
to go out to a club okay so whoo like a
little 13 o'clock people yeah 13 o'clock
hanging out together meeting online and
then hanging out that's pretty cool yeah
zack says hey [ __ ] okay oh zach hey
you i just got home from work and my
feet hurt
[Laughter]
what
his knees hurt no feet oh his feet hurt
i thought he said he got back from work
and his knees hurt yeah that would be a
whole other though
what kind of work do you do exactly
i could imagine oh my god
you need this hat
yeah
[Laughter]
tom's gonna load it out for like
whenever people need it
yeah oh my god
uh so bee's nest is here right he's here
so yeah so i will see you talking yeah
yeah yeah right there welcome what
what's what's your problem
you got like you got live chat is it on
it's on live chat i don't see him you
don't know what's happening
so uh yeah he sent us all this [ __ ] here
he just sent us all this cool [ __ ] here
i was going to show this
uh but yeah check this out
got a little
oh he finally focused
that's pretty awesome and
look at it let's do a little one for
okay there's a little one
a little more
look how cool
focus focus focus focus there we go
awesome right
completely awesome and then
also this one
look at that
yeah
show the back
look it's not beautiful yeah
that's awesome man we're gonna put that
we're gonna put that back in there that
little thing yeah we can move that we
can move the little uh puffy witch off
there
but uh
you know put those put those back there
too sorry those pookies cat toys are all
over the
floor
the ones that elsa's at like pookie's
really into like those little mousies
and those little uh the little scrunchy
balls
so i've been throwing them around for
but i try to keep it clean in here but
yeah how's that working out not so well
as you can see
so
what are you up to today tom
i've been sleeping
sleeping and working out you know what
watching tv so like last night check
this [ __ ] out yeah
so you know i was working yesterday like
i was i was actually finishing um house
of leaves because i did a review of it
today
so that's what i was doing most of the
day like in the afternoon so he goes out
to uh on his motorcycle he you went out
to the biker bar i'm assuming yeah i
ended up over there yeah that's where
you always end up yeah so he goes out to
the biker bar you were gone probably
what like three hours something like
that
and he comes back at 6 or 6 30 or
whatever time it was yeah and so i was
like i i worked a little bit longer and
i said okay i guess i'm going to go like
relax in the bedroom whatever and i go
in there and he's laying on the bed and
all his clothes going
yeah and he was it's like 6 30 or 7.
yeah and so i was like well [ __ ]
so
i said well i guess i'll kind of like
chill out so i chill out and on the bed
and like i put on netflix and i started
watching midnight mass
and uh i kind of got through most of the
first episode but all i could hear the
whole time was
and i was just kind of like god [ __ ]
damn it so i had to come back here in my
office
and watch it because i'm like i can't
concentrate she's [ __ ] i can't no
it's true though i can't concentrate on
this [ __ ] so i had to stay in my office
until like 11 o'clock like watching
netflix on my computer because i
couldn't concentrate on the show because
she restored itself
see
see what happened was at the doctor
the doctor at the [ __ ] at the hrt
clinic [ __ ] put me on a new [ __ ]
hrt protocol
gave me a new kind of [ __ ] test
no new kind of testosterone
and i'm leveling up right now this
shit's [ __ ] powerful
yeah i'm leveling up and it's uh
um it's some special [ __ ] and it uh
i'm starting to [ __ ] i'm starting to
[ __ ] sweat out that crisco again
going through third puberty number three
oh boy i'm around with the appearance
i've been going through your number
no i'm going to keep it under wraps okay
but um just just don't go beating up the
neighbors and stuff
[ __ ] two or three showers a day it's
like [ __ ] smelling like a [ __ ]
wild ass gorilla
socks [ __ ] getting stinky everything
stinking
change everything
and um
man you can work out like a [ __ ]
beast
if you can only do 15 reps with that
same weight
on this [ __ ] you do like 20 or 25
and then you're instantly sore
afterwards and as soon as you stop
moving it's going sleep sleep sleep
you're going
to remember
remember how it was when i first went on
test yeah and [ __ ] it was costly like
morphine where if you stop moving you
want to sleep
remember we out in front of the club we
were drinking all night
and aurora
was [ __ ]
going yeah look at him yeah you know
[ __ ] man you snap right back and i'm
sitting there behind you because you're
getting sleepy honey yeah yeah because
that test is making you sleepy one yeah
just remember that yeah even people
noticing because she knows yeah she's
like she's making you sleep you're gonna
go yeah
i can't even sleep like through a full
night anymore yeah i usually wake up
every two or three hours you might do
something bad
but
i don't know in some ways i don't mind
it you get used to it after a while you
get it you you build up a you build up a
tolerance
until you start changing doses or
changing compounds and then it happens
all over again
it was really weird because this morning
i woke up and i was kind of like man it
must be really early because it was
really dark but
i don't know if you can hear that
there's like howling wind outside it has
been like
completely dark and raining all day
which is fine with me um i don't really
care but honestly it was almost 8
o'clock and i was which is late for me
because i usually wake up like around 6
30. but it was so dark this morning that
i was like i woke up and i was like oh
[ __ ] it's probably only like 5 30 a.m
but it was actually eight o'clock
because it was so [ __ ] dark outside
yeah
beasna says i wake myself up on my own
snoring
yeah i've done that once or twice where
like if i fell asleep on my back like
while i was watching a movie and then
like i'll snore once and be like oh
that's me okay
[Music]
but yeah so
so i had to so i had to come in here she
snores too though i know but it's like
there's been times where she's just
[ __ ] snoring so loud and everything
but thing is i don't throw a fit she
gets mad about it because it wakes no
because it wakes me up about it i don't
wait i wake up i don't even wake her up
i just push on her until she rolls
she'll roll over yeah but i've done that
before and you've like flipped out like
and then you get mad
you know remember and i'm just kind of
like
and then i'm awake and then i'll lay
there for like two hours and i'm like
[ __ ] me and i was like now i'm like
laying here awake a lot of times i just
get up if you talk to me i'll wake up
but if you [ __ ] just push me over
i'll just roll over usually
it's just you can't engage the brain if
you ask these questions i'll wake right
up
well when i when i came in the room last
night because i was like going to watch
something on netflix because i'm
standing there looking at him
laying there and i'm just kind of like
[ __ ] dude it's like should i just like
try to watch something in here and
or should i not wake him up and i wasn't
really sure and i was like [ __ ] it and i
started watching something and then
i was kind of like hey
hey
and like he just didn't he just laid
there snoring the whole time so i was
just kind of like well
i guess i'll go back in my office and
watch tv
because i can't hear anything i mean i
have to i have to put the i have to put
the subtitles on anyway because i'm deaf
but that was the first day on that new
proof new protocol they got me on see
well that was what was weird is that so
you slept essentially from like 7 00 p.m
until i guess it was like 11. i woke a
couple i woke up a couple times like in
the morning and then i went back to
sleep like a week yeah it's like and
then i came in and went to bed um
uh zach says jenny did you ever tell tom
about that script
um
i i did you read once it was looking
through it recently i forgot how good it
was
i don't remember i don't think so what
are you doing back there she's um
do you know what uh
yeah i don't i don't think i did
actually i don't think i did
i was laughing at something pookie did
earlier i was in here recording i'm like
sitting in this spot and i was like
recording a book review and pookie was
sleeping in the chair behind me
like she usually does because she likes
to hang out with mama but she's like
sleeping
and so i've been talking for about 20
minutes and all of a sudden from behind
me i hear
yeah and she was like laying there with
her with her paw over her face but she
kind of like sat up like
like shut up mama why are you talking
you're keeping me awake yeah i walked in
here this morning and it said what's up
don't talk to me
she's cranky until she gets her coffee
she talks she vocalizes and stuff she'll
answer questions hey how you doing
[Laughter]
she knows when you're talking to her
even though she's not really she's not
much of a meower no she always kind of
goes
she also doesn't hiss
oh beijing pulled that thing yesterday
where she came beijing came swishing
through this office yesterday yeah so
she's trying to like assert her
dominance she's like hey i own the
second floor too [ __ ] yeah and then
i don't know so i was like oh you got
past like the little pooky
checkpoint yeah because pookie stands
there by the thing with her little paws
sticking out through the through the
bars like because she does it like if i
go up and down too like i'm going to the
laundry room or something and i come out
and she kind of like swishes at my at my
leg
okay
so today is open lines friday
everybody's getting ready to go out and
party
we can talk about anything today any
kind of questions you guys have about
paranormal stuff
uh [ __ ] anything you know if you want
guys want to talk about [ __ ] uh um uh
if you want tom nostra thomas to try to
predict the future uh [ __ ] i can even
do future headlines
survivalism [ __ ] how to survive the
damn apocalypse [ __ ] survival skills
military skills anything everything is
on the [ __ ] table
including [ __ ]
health and [ __ ]
working out or weight loss or
recomposition's like please ask me about
that please ask me about that please
i could talk about 80s more or yeah we
can talk about some stuff that jenny
likes too
i'm not saying that i'm just going
through the whole list
you know we always talk about your you
you pick the topics all the time well
the audience picks the topic yeah it's
like yeah but it yeah
trey says my girlfriends and ex-wife
have all said that i don't snore i guess
that's a good thing yeah it is i you
know it's just kind of like
man
i try not to like ever fall asleep on my
back
because i think that's the only time i
do but yeah you know what i mean it is
when you're on your back yeah but it's i
don't you know i usually sleep on my
side yeah i usually if i'll fall asleep
like sometimes if i'm watching something
like sometimes i'll fall asleep on my
back and then i'll start to snore but
like i said a lot of times it'll i'll
wake myself up because i'll be like
yeah you know and this little wake me up
thank you dermot
london calling tom's sexy image has
reminded me of william friedkin's
cruising from 1980
a review of that would be interesting uh
have you seen it that's the gay scene
from the 80s yeah yeah yeah i haven't
seen it it's good i've watched it
probably
uh probably like six months ago i think
i watched it um i'd seen it before but
it had been like many years and i just
wanted to revisit it it's good i liked
it a lot right
[Laughter]
okay um
these nests asked me what the pros and
cons of full metal jacket ammo are uh
there are no cons everything is a pro
with full metal jacket
well that was easy yeah
um
okay
i used to be a [ __ ] big believer
in the hollow points hollow point
theories for law enforcement out of
pistol caliber cartridges and rifles
actually with rifles and hunting it did
make a difference we noticed that in the
field there's a lot of stuff
that
that you would think
you would think that a hollow point
bullet would dominate all military and
law enforcement scenarios and i'm going
to say no full metal jacket does
um
it
they'll come out and say well it has to
do with preventing over penetration so
the bullet doesn't go through the target
or guy you're aiming and hit innocent
bystander that has never happened in the
history of law enforcement even with
full metal jackets that's not a
statistically that's not a problem
anything that kills you
any any form any hollow point
any strike with a hollow point bullet
would have also killed you if it was
full metal jacket
anybody who's ever survived a full metal
jacket hit they would have survived it
also if it was a hollow point
that whole hollow point thing
i think was more marketing gimmick
looking back on it even though i
believed it
bought a lot of them shot a lot of them
it made a difference in animals in
smaller
calibers
um
things like nozzle ballistic tips out of
308 and stuff would hit deer we tried
different bullet weights and we were
hand loading them keeping track of what
the velocity was
we were mostly what made the difference
and made the stopping power wasn't
really that bullet configuration it was
shot placement shot placements
everything
so i i started to question
the full metal jacket i started to
question hollow points
now there's one exception there's
something called a um
under uh a company called underwood
makes something called extreme
penetrator and it looks like us it's a
solid
copper bullet if i remember correctly i
think it's all copper
and it's got a head on it looks like a
phillips screwdriver
and it that thing penetrates better than
any full metal jacket and when you look
at the wound ballistics on it it's as
good as a hollow point and it doesn't
expand at all it's just fluid dynamics
and that's the future i think hollow
points are probably obsolete now the
stuff like that exists because it can do
both jobs that thing will go through
more steel than a full metal jacket
question for tom are you an extreme
penetrator
i'm an extreme penetrator i'm an extreme
violator
i'm the dominator where's my bull went
actually i'm
don't worry about i got that [ __ ] coming
i got my i got my dominator outfit
coming his dominator outfit yeah
all right grampur's hammer also has a
question question for tom the chinese
government is telling its population to
stock up in case of emergency should we
be readying for war as well
um
not with them
not with china if anything happens in
the united states it's going to be
two you know two two different
interpretations of america trying to
separate from one another you might end
up with something temporarily like east
germany and west germany
uh although there won't be a civil war
in in the conventional sense like you
had in the first thing that they called
the civil war which was not a civil war
it was a war between states a war of
secession
it was the beginning of the america in
the form of an empire
um all that [ __ ] was [ __ ] dastardly
the civil the history of behind the
civil war is pretty contaminated with a
bunch of partisan [ __ ] um
you just had two different cultures that
were both the united states that just
couldn't stand each other and then
slavery became an issue
um but
the people that fought on the south if
you asked them if you asked them well
you fighting to defend slavery they're
like no
they didn't they didn't see it that way
on the ground
um they just saw it as that they were
fighting to defend their homeland
against
an ethnic invader that they just
couldn't stand it and a lot of stuff has
been lost in modern history a lot of the
details have been erased what was being
said in newspapers on both sides there
was a big ethnic component to that the
south was a lot more kind of
celtic and germanic
ethnicity to it and
the whites in the north were just more
anglo and this was like some this was
kind of a blood feud that went back into
the honky motherland
they
i talked we touched it we touched on it
a couple times
some modern people get very confused
about america and race
um nationality and race were considered
to be the same thing in the 1800s if you
descended from the irish then that was
your race you were irish if you
descended from the english then that was
your race you were english an
anglo-american or an irish american the
same thing even though they were mixing
and they were changing their last names
everyone was trying to appear as english
as possible in certain
periods of history you didn't want to
look like an alien invading ethnic
minority like irish or
german
or hungarian although now later on in
the 20th century that didn't matter as
much but in the 18th century it was even
the 19th century it did in the 18th
century did too
um that sticks up their boats back then
yeah well there was bad blood from back
in europe
you know same [ __ ] would have went down
if the united states was colonized by
africans
they would be bad blood of what happened
back in africa 100 years before that
between those tribes it was the same
dynamic
so um
there was like i said the the war of the
war between the states had an ethnic
component to it
um it won't be like that again um
it won't be a conventional war it will
be this new fifth generation war
which does not involve any standing
armies it's political it's propaganda
uh it's memes
uh mind control
you see uh conventional warfare and i
was trained for it and i was trained for
the ultimate incarnation of [ __ ]
conventional war and that was world war
three which involved [ __ ] nuclear and
biological weapons and everything oh
that's what we were training for that
war never happened
um
but all of that is now
obsolete uh and that would in that
world war three style which would have
been third generation i think or fourth
generation i think fourth generation
warfare what that
no i think it was third i think is what
they called it
um
it wouldn't have worked either
um
if you go back through the history of
warfare
it wasn't the
armies and the weapons that won what
happened was is that somebody gave up
here's an example so it was always a
battle of wills
it wasn't really never a battle between
conventional armies like for instance in
the 1700s
when we were trying to
uh separate from the english
empire we never really won any battles
against the british
they kicked our asses mostly
and then and after that thing happened
the british never really
considered us to be a separate
nation from them they still considered
us a colony they didn't recognize
anything that we called a victory they
were just like nah
that's that's still britain over there
and that went on until the 1800s until
the battle of
1812 and uh with jackson
and the british [ __ ] came down
[ __ ] up the white house and attacked
the capital and [ __ ] burned a bunch
of [ __ ] down
i think they burned the white house down
dolly madison and president madison
[ __ ] ran it was just [ __ ] chaos
the the british decisively kicked our
asses in that battle
we didn't win that war
not really it's just the british gave up
they realized that
we can't control this we can't you know
the more we beat up on these americans
the less they'll listen to us so they
just gave up went home
and that was the same thing that
happened to us in vietnam and
afghanistan and all these other little
[ __ ] korea was kind of like that
and other people's wars are kind of like
that
if you're not killing them all out to
the last man and performing genocide on
them you're not gonna win until they
give up and they tend not to give up
so it doesn't work
this new fifth generation does work
there's no open fighting you just
[ __ ] bombard the enemy with lies
[ __ ] propaganda get them to destroy
themselves fragment their own country
get them to hate themselves uh
get them to stop reproducing and then
you just take them out of a leadership
position on the world stage that's how
you do it and then when you're done with
them they don't even know that they were
attacked
you do it by buying up all their media
and bribing their politicians and
bribing their [ __ ] oligarchs to sell
out the nation and that's what's
happening now
that's this is real war
and it's just it's called fifth
generational warfare
and they just get you to quit
and that works
that's a warfare that works
these trinkets these [ __ ] jets and
tanks and [ __ ] like doesn't work
you could send a tank out
that's why when the soviet union was
falling apart they didn't really call
the army out they knew they wouldn't do
anything those tanks just sit there
what are they gonna do shoot at
civilians nobody's listening
that's that's how they go that's how
countries fall apart
zach says here's a topic favorite movie
not in the horror genre
like are there any dramas you like for
instance um
favorite drama amadeus
yeah
favorite comedy
the original
ghostbusters although there's a lot of
competition there's a lot of competition
for both
young frankenstein is good too my
favorite comedy was idiocracy
that was [ __ ] good i liked that one
i'm not i don't know there's like
there's a really lot of awesome movies
that came out like in the 80s and 90s
that i'm super into like i said i really
really like amadeus that was the first
movie that i bought on dvd
uh and i still re-watch it every year or
so um i'm also really into dangerous
liaisons i like that a lot too
um yeah so there's a [ __ ] on movies i
like all different kind of movies i'll
watch pretty much anything to be honest
with you if it's if it's good yeah i
don't give a crap what like uh genre it
is horror is my favorite that's just
what i always kind of uh you know
gravitate to but
if if shit's good like i said comedies
are kind of like hit or miss for me
because i have a really peculiar like
sense of humor
so
a lot of comedies i watch and they're
just like not that funny to me but
i don't know um but yeah so that's kind
of like the hardest thing to get right
in my eyes but
you know uh esther says
jenny a24 and the coen brothers are
coming with the tragedy of macbeth
starring denzel washington and france
mcdormand in mid-january shot in black
and white holy [ __ ]
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna hop on
that because man
that that's gonna be awesome that's
gonna be awesome macbeth is my favorite
shakespeare play
uh granthar says a question for tom
based on your experience what are the
most effective methods to tame a wild
woman
this should be good
i don't know how you defend how you how
you how do you actually
like one of them
there's always a way but the thing is is
you might not want to tame a wild woman
you might just want to [ __ ] ride that
wave you know i'm talking about you just
you just appeal to the woman that's how
you do it
if you can't appeal to her then that's
not then you might need to move on you
know man's got to understand his limits
i've seen all kinds of dudes
trying to [ __ ] pick up women in bars
and that [ __ ] women's like four times
his [ __ ] caliber you know i mean and
he doesn't even have a chance he just
looks like a [ __ ] fool you know
well i don't know and like i said this
is a generalization obviously not
everybody uh you know fits into this
these categories but in general
in a very broad sense
um
dudes no matter what they look like or
no matter what they act like they tend
to overestimate
they tend to be overconfident
and women no matter what they look like
tend to be underconfident not always
but
in broad strokes
so
that's why you kind of see these things
where these dudes who are just kind of
like
not even all that
um you see them kind of like aiming much
higher than they probably should be yeah
just because they really don't think
that
i mean they think they're awesome even
though there's nothing really to back
that up yeah
that's something that always
that's kind of
whereas whereas i've known
you know i've known women i've had women
friends who were like gorgeous and
awesome and everything like that and
just like thought they were pieces of
[ __ ] and were like deformed and stuff
you know what i mean it's very very
common yeah i guess guys don't really
see it because they don't really show
that side to us
yeah
well yeah you you have to kind of keep
that on the down the down low
so you don't know who's like that but i
just find it
i find it [ __ ] very myopic very
[ __ ] like
self-centered they got this dude's
looking at some chick
and sure and physically
i'm not even talking about her
personality because that's really not
the first thing guys see all right the
guys are just very visual they're going
for how things look and the way she
behaves her mannerisms and stuff
what she's wearing
and she might be like a 9 out of 10 or a
10 out of 10 or a [ __ ] 11 out of 10
and this dude's going oh yeah oh and he
can't figure out why
he can't get that and you're looking at
him and he's like a three
well we got into this a little bit on
the insell show and then and then what
happens is that dude yeah like he gets
mad like he goes up and like hits on her
and she's just kind of like you know
dismissive or no i'm with somebody or
something like that and then he's like
[ __ ] yeah or dyke yeah or something
like that or some [ __ ] like that like
first who wouldn't want to [ __ ] me i'm
so awesome yeah first of all you wait
what you're wearing is [ __ ] up okay
that's first thing what you're wearing
is totally are you are those crocs yeah
just by the way she's dressed she's not
looking for you okay
all right that's the first thing second
thing is dude you don't have any damn
money you know what i mean you don't
you're not you don't have a job okay
that's not
three dude you ugly
well it's like i said it's not even so
much that because it's like you're way
overweight and [ __ ] you know what i
mean you you you really haven't done
anything you haven't taken care of
yourself
you don't [ __ ] have any physicality
to you that woman is [ __ ] built like
a ballet dancer and you're a [ __ ]
bowl of jelly and you think you're gonna
get you're [ __ ] crazy
it's just
dudes have to [ __ ] understand who
they are
know thyself okay i kind of feel like it
was maybe all those 90s sitcoms that
always had like a
like a pudgy dude with a super hot wife
yeah that's tv yeah
that's another thing
these movies and televisions i think you
talked to the average
100 iq [ __ ]
john q public normie
most of their opinions and expectations
of the world have come from [ __ ]
cheap ass television programs and
[ __ ] second-rate movies and just
hollywood movies and there is no reality
in those things
in any of those movies well most of them
don't have any reality in them well yeah
it's fiction you know it's kind of based
on you know
[ __ ] that's like sort of people can
relate to but it's like it's dramatized
it's fictionalized and also that
everybody in those movies is an actor
that's not you know [ __ ] like they'll
show a board room or something into some
big corporation
that's actors playing people in board
rooms you go into a real board room
they're not going to look like that you
know i don't look like that at all
yeah not everybody looks like right and
there's probably not going to be any
diversity you know you're going to a
banking go into a banking board room and
you're going to see one kind of dude 80
year old white dudes
yeah
yeah
pretty much that's who runs those banks
granthar's hammer says my wife is 13
years younger than me and totally hot i
way overplayed the hand i was dealt
thank you again zach
a movie i love is chinatown that yeah
that is pretty awesome like i said
there's a lot of competition amadeus was
just the first one i thought of because
i've seen that movie a million times uh
it's beautifully shot and the acting is
super subtle which is weird because it's
jack nicholson
yeah to be honest he's kind of sexy in
it too jack nicholson was actually kind
of sexy back in the back in the day you
know what i mean yeah although
he was one of those guys i kind of feel
like this happened with a lot of actors
that generation where they seemed much
older than they actually were like
before like they almost seemed like not
old guys but they almost seemed like
middle-aged when they were still young
yeah i mean i've seen jack nicholson
like when he was really young like
like in little no i was gonna say um
like in little shop of horrors like the
roger corman one from the 60s and he
looks real young in that and i'm like
wow look how like look how foxy he was
back then but it just seems like once
the 70s came along he already looked
middle-aged even though he wasn't
drinking heavy i think and uh just the
lifestyle we talk about that a lot like
because i do kind of feel like
that i don't know man that happened a
lot like with those actors most of those
dudes did not work out
that's part of it they thought a man was
just it had to just be
strong and powerful by force of his own
will working out was cheating
i can see that all you gotta do is just
look at some of those [ __ ] action
movies at the time those dudes are
[ __ ] scrawny [ __ ] clint eastwood
was scrawny [ __ ]
i guess scrawny all right he's like a
kite that dude wouldn't weigh anything
some of them though were [ __ ]
bad ass charles bronson you look at
charles bronson he's kind of he's he's
about my size i think by looking by
looking at the build
and
his height and build compared to other
people because they always lie about how
tall they are i think they claim charles
bronson is like
[ __ ] five foot eight and i'm going uh
charles bronze is probably more like
five foot six i kind of feel like if
you're under five foot eight if you're a
man yeah uh they always just say five
foot eight five foot even though like i
said that's so dumb it's like i don't
know i i guess that's something maybe
that's a thing but it was never
literally never anything that i thought
about like in relation to like oh
man go look at [ __ ] charles bronson
in his 40s and 50s with his shirt off
you can look googled in [ __ ] photos
he was [ __ ] ready for action
all right he was [ __ ] twice my size
he was [ __ ] big
and um he understood about [ __ ] hrt
and [ __ ] anabolics all that
technology was there it's just that only
gym rats knew about it and real high
tech doctors which
in those days was one of the same things
those doctors that were prescribing that
[ __ ] were in those gems working out with
those dudes they were also researching
the development of that [ __ ] and it was
happening in california because they
were making it all in mexico where she
came from
that's why i [ __ ] muscle beach and
arnie and all those guys that's all
mexican steroids mexican testosterone
and [ __ ]
but um
if you're
in your 40s man after 35 you're a man
you can start losing muscle mass your
[ __ ] your shit's going to slow down
you can start getting fat it's just how
it is
ask my [ __ ] boy bees nest that's my
student right there
he went on hrt i've been helping him
online he's lost nearly a hundred pounds
nearly 100 because his hormones are
right he's not he can now metabolize i
think he said you lost what 80 pounds
bees 80 pounds just in what maybe
four or five months
and and
just basic
weightlifting
just nothing you know he's
but it's just because your hormones are
right once you get that
ability to synthesize
protein and burn fat like you had it
back when you were 15 or 16 you'll lose
a lot of weight
just eating regular food
remember how fast you burnt [ __ ] off
when you were a kid you just get that
back
the technology's there there's no
downside
just don't abuse it
but hard to abuse it when you're in your
40s or 50s because you don't have enough
time left to really abuse much i mean
you really have to overdo it
and you if you had heart stints or if
you have a weak heart i wouldn't
recommend it go check it out with your
doctor and get an hrt clinic before it's
too late
that's my
that's my
i recommend that to men and women
because women need testosterone too
after menopause it's a very small dose
helps out a lot
it's just funny to me too a lot of times
i mean this just goes to show but
uh you know a lot of people say like
when they were younger when they were
teenagers um you know it's like oh i
could eat whatever i wanted and yeah you
know lose weight it's like i i never had
that luxury
um i had to do the way you were
energized
so i mean
seriously i was skinny when i was a kid
but as soon as i went through puberty i
started to pork out yeah just
immediately just had to do with the way
you were androgenized so i didn't have
that thing because i and some girls have
it too where they you know they can just
like eat like crap and you know until
they're in their 20s and then they start
getting fat but it's like i didn't i
didn't ever have that it was probably
just something having to do with the
aromatization of of testosterone into
estrogen or estrogen production had you
gotten blood tests back then and if they
knew if science wasn't that good when we
were that when we were kids anyway
that's true they didn't know what was
going on during a lot of those they
always normal she allowed girl [ __ ] like
that they could have gone in there and
[ __ ] went uh yeah okay she needs this
and that and that'll [ __ ] she needs
to have her hormones slightly more
balanced and if you probably would have
stayed the same way something like that
and uh [ __ ] man going back in time i'm
5'6 but [ __ ] back in those days if i
were
knowing what they know now that i could
have gone to the [ __ ] uh one of those
clinics and say man i'm i'm not as tall
as i want to be my bones have a solid
solidified they give you hgh you'll pick
up another three inches of [ __ ]
height right there
before your skeleton's [ __ ] set
they got they got they're doing that
we know uh we had students female
writing students that weren't growing
very big and their
parents sent them to the uh to the
[ __ ] thing and gave some shouts and
the next thing you know you see her and
she's looking
five
seven happened in like [ __ ]
four or five months
yeah i just got to five two and
then stopped
turned her into like a ballerina
they're talking about like uh funny
scenes in movies uh scenes in the
prostitutes department in uh mighty
aphrodite yeah i remember that one i saw
that in the theater actually that was
really good grampur's favorites at the
moment the wrestler oh my god that's
that movie is amazing actually have you
seen that with uh mickey rourke
no you'd probably like that actually you
should say i saw that in the theater too
uh sideways also good i think i saw that
in the theater too
um he's answering to me yeah camp guy
says oh raising arizona yeah i forgot
about that one that's another favorite
comedy of mine actually
and i still haven't seen a brother where
art thou i really need to see that
jesus says yeah weight is coming off
you lost around 80.
he says i recommend any man over 40 get
on test yep
well like i said in general i think it's
always been easier for men to lose
weight than women women's bodies just
like to hang on to it it's so it's
harder
you know hormone therapy
no i'm just saying like in general in
general yeah yeah yeah women women's
bodies are just kind of like no we need
that fat just in case yeah women are not
as hormonal
in terms of in terms of uh testosterone
as men and
the a woman's main hormone is
testosterone people think it's estrogen
it is it's mostly test it's just that
they're ten times they have ten times
less than a man
of it
and um
when they get pregnant they start to
aromatize they start to produce and
aromatize more estrogen somehow estrogen
is about get being kind of
watery and pudgy and getting ready for
birth you know turn you into damn human
egg like an alien just like that that's
what estrogen does
but um
if you look at those real [ __ ] hot
instagram models that's test and
anabolics
make it real lean shapely
but it can happen within the normal
realm too
like you know
some some girls just genetically have
that
so
it depends on what their test levels are
sorry i was laughing at camp guy quoting
raising arizona
the doctor explained that her womb was a
rocky place where my seed could find no
purchase yeah
[Laughter]
i just realized
i think when we watch that one uh sophie
was here because me and sophie really
liked that movie but man i love that
movie so much
uh i have it on dvd somewhere
um
yeah that's actually that's not from
raising arizona is i think that's from
um wild at heart grand there's is it not
because isn't that one the one where uh
yeah cause laura dern was in wild at
heart the david lynch movie i need to
get that on blu-ray actually
i saw that movie so many times like
growing up and
i love that one too willem dafoe's in
that
and then
we me and my me and my friends used to
quote each other all the time like in
high school about that about the thing
about
the dog and wizard of oz
it's like i don't even remember what it
was but it was [ __ ] funny yeah it was
wild at heart that's what i thought
yeah because he calls her peanut
i remember that
death becomes her yeah that's also a
good one we just reviewed that one not
too long ago had you ever seen that
before we reviewed it yeah yeah
i really like that one too that was
another one that was on cable all the
time
yeah laura dern doesn't age she really
doesn't
i mean now i haven't seen her in a while
i saw her
um
obviously i saw an inland empire but
that was a long time ago
we'll get some more of this ice okay
actually turn the ice maker off so we're
[ __ ] we're real low on ice so we're
just gonna have to drink some room
temperatures
temperature vodka hopefully it's making
nice as we're doing the show
well the juices go
okay that's true here
that's the last of that all right i'll
go and get some more later
i'm making my lunch
that was jingle bell
good old crisp and glover
[Laughter]
oh my god crispin glover was like such a
weird dude well i'm sure he's still a
weird dude
one of these days still wasn't he was in
a remake of
ben like the rat movie right
i think the original is on to be but um
i haven't seen the i've saw the remake
with chrisman glover but
he just seems like a really really weird
dude yeah something's wrong with him
that's okay though i mean you know he
made a whole [ __ ] career out of it if
you're gonna if you're gonna be a weirdo
let's like lean into the [ __ ] he was
making a um a movie with a bunch of like
mentally [ __ ] kids in it remember
that one
every or they all played a role i don't
know if he ever finished it he was
catching all kinds of flack about it
i don't know how long ago was that oh 20
30 years ago that sounds vaguely
familiar yeah
i think he was in it and then everybody
else was like but what was funny is like
i think they were supposed
they were just supposed to be normal
people but everybody in it was was was
mentally [ __ ]
but they weren't supposed to be they
were just playing normal roles
and i don't know you know how cuz he's
real into the surrealism and stuff yeah
yeah so that's did you guys ever see
um
bartleby
which was a loose adaptation of bartleby
the scrivener
where is basically about a dude that
goes to work at a place and causes all
kind of chaos because quote unquote i
would prefer not to like everything they
ask him to do he's like i'd prefer not
to dj maniacs answering it you answer
what i said
yeah the one tom is talking about is his
long-form art project called what is it
okay it's in three parts he said
i love it i love it
even come out was it i don't know
[Laughter]
yeah dj maniac says oh i loved bartleby
i did too i really want to see that
again actually me and my friend used to
watch that all the time holy crap i had
that one on dvd too i don't know what
happened to it but yeah that was a
really good one
man crisp and glow i was you know what
it's like i said if you're gonna be
weird like that just [ __ ] lean into
it man it's like and that's not
the thing about about him that i like is
that he's legitimately weird that's not
a pose you know what i mean
um
and i like that because there's it's sad
because there's so many people that are
genuinely weird and they don't they're
not the kind of weird that would get
them the kind of accolades that crisp
and glover would get he says that he
screens it from time to time at film
festivals really yeah
i would actually like to see it
now i'm intrigued yeah
you can probably see it you probably see
it on youtube or something yeah we'll
have to look that [ __ ] up yeah dj maniac
says he's also written a number of weird
fiction books yeah i thought he had i
thought he had i haven't read any of
them though because i've you know but he
had a house that's filled with like
gynecological tables and [ __ ] like that
oh very cronenberg yeah
uh logical stuff and
medical stuff in his house
so what he had like the he had like the
stirrups and the stirrups with the thing
and just all kinds of weird [ __ ] in his
house that was like his furniture
all right well you know the table with
the stirrups on it you could you could
use that for things
no
i think what i think what it was is that
he just
collected weird junk and put it in his
house anything it was kind of shocking
but like i said some people there's a
fine line between
doing that
as opposed as in look how weird i am
and doing that because you're a
genuinely weird person who's into that
kind of [ __ ] i don't think he's wealthy
either
no i don't think so either he got i
remember i was watching um the david
letterman show and david letterman
kicked him off a [ __ ] show
[Laughter]
he started doing karate and [ __ ] and you
kicked and you almost kicked uh
oh [ __ ] uh david letterman in the
[ __ ] head
it's like okay that's it that's it okay
about you're outta here
and then when the when they came back he
wasn't there
then they stalled for time through the
segment and then they brought in the
next guest
yeah that was the last time i saw crisp
and glover oh yeah what he's doing
nowadays i don't know
i don't know and i don't think that was
an act
he's on something that's what i mean i
don't think
you know i it was awesome i don't know
like like i said you might just be a
weird person weird person on drugs well
yeah that probably doesn't help
but um yeah beezness said was andy
warhol truly weird at just acting i kind
of see with andy warhol it was hard to
tell but i do kind of feel like that was
mostly a pose he's like he's larvin um
he he hung out with a lot of genuinely
weird people yeah
um
but
i don't know there's kind of like
sometimes it's hard to tell but
i don't know
sometimes if you if
if you're if you try to be weird it
comes across as like try hard and kind
of desperate and like that whole scene
with him and eddie
and [ __ ] twiggy and [ __ ] velvet
underground underground people
i think they're posers
they were
i think they were
ahead of their time and in some ways you
know in in many ways actually especially
musically they were kind of almost like
proto-gothic
or proto-cold wave
types you know kind of like that was
kind of like
from that kind of came some really cool
[ __ ]
but i think they were also kind of
hamming it up if you ask me
it kind of
i didn't get that i didn't get that so
much from um
from like the members of the volvo
underground no but from people like more
like andy warhol yeah kind of where
you know they they seemed at least
self-aware enough to
be like yeah we're going to do weird
stuff for the just sake of being weird
yeah as i was going to say the people
who weren't very talented were putting
it on
the people from the velvet underground
were kind of talented
um even oh nico even though she couldn't
hold a tune was still kind of talented
in a way she kind of had a
kind of a rustic charm to her voice
yeah she kind of was like a
kind of like a goth singer really a lot
of the girls well yeah i mean the marble
index a lot of people
consider that like a like a proto yeah
album
so from early 70s but edie was just the
cutie
just
just high as [ __ ] and be famous for
being high and cute
and twiggy famous for being high and
being skitty yeah yeah being like cute
too even even in a even an era where
everybody was like
kidding yeah
and
i think we're all i had a good eye for
certain things yeah he was mostly just
manipulating the media at the time and
um
but from what i've read and heard about
him you know through other people just
be reading not personally but reading
what they said about him and knowing
people in the boston scene
in the early 90s who kind of some of the
old ones who were in their 50s when i
knew them back then
kind of came out of that era
they were all kind of like that a little
bit poser-ish kinda well like i said i
kind of feel like
he had a good instinct
for
what was gonna be like the next big
thing yeah
but
he like i said he was at least
self-aware enough to be able to
manipulate
uh opinion to how he wanted so so like i
said it's almost kind of like
so there's some kind of calculating yeah
so i think that's what it is i think
that that
if you're trying too hard to be weird
like you're trying to i'm going to
capture the weird market whatever that
is so i think there's like a calculating
thing behind it which is really like
unappealing to me
um rather than somebody that is just
genuinely weird and people just like
came across them and just people kind of
organically like them because like look
how [ __ ] weird that is
um you know like i said there's a fine
line and sometimes you can't really tell
but
i genuinely don't like if people are
trying to be weird yeah you know what
i'm saying
i think the economy were a little bit
they were trying to be salvador dali
kind of did that
but he was a weird dude too
but salvador dali was also a product of
the media they knew how to play the
media yeah that's what they were and but
so did other guys like bowie they were
playing the media they had they know how
to get what they want they knew who
the media who they were as individuals
what they were like and knew how to
appeal to them personally to get them to
write some [ __ ] about them
and um
a guy like warhol could see something
that was cool and say this is going to
be their next biggest thing and the way
the media would write about it because
they were they had a positive view of
warhol they would make sure that that
would happen so they would kind of like
fulfill
it was like fulfilling a prophecy
you know they would make sure that that
would become the next thing even though
it probably didn't stick because a lot
of the [ __ ] that he did people kind of
laughed at it
like taking a [ __ ] what was it a
ferrari and painting it with a finger
finger paint
it was kind of a joke
you know
people didn't start finger painting the
ferraris
yeah yeah i mean it's just a one time
thing thank you victor what do you say
he gave us a super chat and it says hey
i made it i missed you people we missed
you too
uh and also thank you again zach i know
a lot of people think warhol was on the
spectrum maybe
personally i think kubrick was too um
yeah i definitely think probably stanley
could i don't think i don't think i
don't think uh
i don't think what's his name was though
um [ __ ]
anyway yeah i don't think we're all was
on the spectrum though he was just
i think based on what what they said
about him
you're dealing with a kind of a shy
gay dude who's basically still kind of
semi-closeted
he liked young pretty guys and took
pictures of him and
that was how you met andy warhol so i
can show him some pretty boys and
[ __ ] offered to do a photo shoot type
of deal and then you'd he'd be friends
with you
but um he
he he didn't really i don't recall him
ever really coming out behind that
i don't even think he really
came out as gay i think he just left
people wondering
and well there is there was a certain
thing going on around then where you
just kind of like kept [ __ ] ambiguous
like that was cooler apparently it's
like more cool that was kind of the way
it was in the goth scene well that's
what i was going to say yeah
shit's going on down going on now at the
lgbt thing and [ __ ] weight these
college kids and everything
their gender pronouns and wearing
everything on their [ __ ] sleeve
that would have been very uncool in the
goth scene real uncool
to
to put yourself into any kind of a box
everything was ambiguous and it was
nobody else's business
and
it was just another interpretation of of
what they're talking about i guess in a
certain way
the guys call kind of
usually wanted to have kind of an
androgyny to them
um
that was the look of a lot of the god
scene
um
they could sometimes like come off as
gay but they weren't
they were some of them were but most of
them weren't
it was just kind of like a
part of that style
but it wasn't cool to say you were
straight or gay or anything
yeah everyone was just kind of like yeah
whatever it was kind of like
being goth was a [ __ ] sexual
orientation to itself
that's kind of where it's just we're
just kind of like whatever comes along
yeah
and then if it comes along and we like
it then we're not worried
about it that was that was that was the
air you had to have
it wasn't that way in reality all the
time you know what i mean like no but
that was kind of like the one image that
you wanted especially with the girls the
girls would pull off this [ __ ] big
[ __ ] like trisexual type thing you
know and until it was like okay let's go
[ __ ] this girl oh no no i can't even
please
what are you talking about you know i
thought that uh oh and then she'd make
up some kind of excuse so there was a
lot of [ __ ] imitation bisexual women
in there and there's all kinds of stuff
like that
man i think even back in the 80s the
dead milkman made fun of that one yeah
yeah like talking about everybody in the
gossip was like a fake bisexual
which like i said that's it's not
entirely true but there is some truth to
it there was there were some legitimate
ones in there yeah
there was some truth to it like i'd say
everybody wanted to be
pansexual i guess yeah uh grampur's
hammer says fake weirdos tom green and
andy dick oh yeah i'll agree um
those two i never could get behind those
two guys like i said that they're very
very try hard uh somebody also brought
up john waters i [ __ ] love john
waters john waters
is kind of like the rare exception where
he's just like a genuine weirdo but he's
also like super charming and awesome
yeah he's the real thing that guy like
he can which is weird you don't usually
see those two things together but yeah
he genuinely loves weird [ __ ] and gross
[ __ ] like he's into it that's not a pose
um but he's also just like so cute and
endearing that you just can't
not how can you not love john waters i
mean seriously everybody loves john
waters uh another one that was kind of a
fake but everybody loves him
david bowie
david boy fake bisexual see the thing
about him though is that he david bowie
never he never struck me as a weird
person no no classy
yeah he's not a weird person yeah classy
and artistic well some people might
think he was weird
well yeah but from my point of view or
something from my point of view he's not
weird not at all
like i said all said i was like that's
not weird his dying words this is true
now his dying words were to
tell them i was a closet heterosexual
grampter's hammer also says fake weirdos
marilyn manson yeah
yeah big time yeah and bjork
bjork seems kind of
weird for trails
but um especially maybe back in her like
uh back in her sugar cubes days yeah
but
yeah marilyn manson
that is completely calculated and
honestly
i saw what was that marilyn manson like
band like documentary they did like back
in the 90s i somehow ended up watching
that i must have like rented it from
blockbuster or something
and
the only thing i remember from that was
them just trying really really hard to
be like shocking and gross they're like
hey let's have one of the band members
like poop
on the carpet and then one of us will
pick it up with a fork and eat it and
i'm just kind of like which they
probably didn't do okay
i'm like one gigi allen already did that
[ __ ] and two
why
that's fine you mentioned two people
that were friends of my friends like uh
i can um
um dimitri's friends with
with uh marilyn manson they grew up
together
yeah
yeah and he knew him looking because
he's from here yeah but our friend
dimitri who's a dj
that we work with he
he came up with marilyn manson he said
he was a lot different back
then i don't know if i could talk about
him though he
he he kind of liked him but he thought
that he went down it went down like a
bad path of being kind of a fake that's
kind of
one of the things kind of selling out a
little bit
um yeah i kind of got that yeah when i
was in boston
i hung out with a dude [ __ ] named ty
tyrone it's the only white dude i ever
knew that [ __ ] was named tyrone
and tyrone [ __ ]
he was in another punk rock band and i
always forgetting which one it was i
wanted to say it was in the dead boys
but it wasn't he was he he knew the dead
boys
and he was in another band
i had never heard of it but it had
records and [ __ ] and he knew gigi allen
he said at gg allen when he started was
really good until he went on a couple of
um talk shows it was there was acting a
fool on a talk show
and he realized that he could make more
money and draw a bigger crowd and
wouldn't have to play by being like
outright being outrageous and getting
arrested hey i'm gonna like [ __ ] in my
hand and throw it at the audience and
[ __ ] like that yeah
he got more attention and made more
money doing that and it and he would
they wouldn't even play they wouldn't
even play the show
and um
ty kind of got pissed at him
he got locked up
one day [ __ ] uh gigi got locked up
and got killed in prison and not in real
prison he was just in jail i think it
happened in central lockup he was only
gonna be in there for a few hours and
somebody killed him because he was i got
an ass
and gigi was not a big dude
yeah i mean
he's probably bigger than your average
little punk rocker but he wasn't [ __ ]
physically fit or anything those dudes
[ __ ] worked him over and they
probably said something crazy he didn't
care about getting his ass beat
but he didn't realize in jail you could
get your ass beat to death
and that's what happened
at least that's that's how i heard heard
the story maybe it was different but
that's how i heard the story he got
beaten to death in jail
beezness said didn't divine eat a real
dog turd in that one movie yes
yes
which
man that's that's going pretty far for
your art there it must have been [ __ ]
up
john waters is like well we could do it
fake we could just make it like a melted
tootsie roll or something and divine's
like nah i'm really gonna do that [ __ ]
gross
you i don't i don't even know if there's
any amount of money that you could pay
me to like eat poop
they were crazy back then
well like i said i'm sure [ __ ] drugs
help yeah because then you're just kind
of like hey let's make all the stupid
decisions
i mean i've [ __ ] and i've been like
apocalyptic apocalyptically drunk but i
don't think i've ever been drunk enough
to think that eating poop was a good
idea
so that's that's one thing i have going
for me
some of those girls from that scene did
weird [ __ ] they were [ __ ] making
clandestinely also making porn
some of it got out some of it didn't
which like i said i heard uh i heard
a rumor that uh wendy o williams uh
was doing dog porn doggy porn blowing
dogs and [ __ ] he did at least one film
like that huh in her [ __ ] pock rock
outfit and everything before she was
famous i don't know if it's true
well i will say that
um
[Music]
you know the uh the kind of like um
bestiality porn is like way bigger than
people yeah she did that evidently then
people realize maybe
you know sometimes don't ask me how it
is in some countries it's legal in japan
it is that's like not even a thing
that's which they do yeah
i don't know
because like i said animal can't really
consent to that [ __ ] it's like what are
you even doing back there knock it off
i mean i don't know like to some extent
maybe the animal doesn't care but it's
just kind of like
well man i'll tell you what i don't know
that just seems like a real
slippery slope right there in the 70s
the bdsm underground scene was
supposedly [ __ ] really hardcore and
especially up in europe and it has to
have a band i really like this man it's
a french band called uh die form
and that's some really good goth
industrial music and some of that [ __ ]
had bestiality undertones to it you know
and
um
the videos were quite kind of strange
too
but uh you know [ __ ] songs like
animal fever and [ __ ] like that you know
what i mean and it's just [ __ ] yeah
that's what they're talking about some
people like low-key bc yeah
yeah
enthusiasts
well i mean eve at least in the written
erotica thing a lot of people are into
not necessarily straight bestiality but
um
the kind of the thing where like like
werewolves or
half man half animal yeah that's really
really big i think that might be like
either the biggest or the second biggest
sub genre of erotica at least written
erotica so you know i don't know about
like video porn or anything like that
but yeah old dive forum was [ __ ] good
from the uh 80s 80s 80s and 90s actually
90s that's what it was all throughout
the 90s i liked it uh they had
one album that was called [ __ ]
la mirabas i don't remember it's all the
french french titles mostly
all that french yeah it's french stuff
it's it's most of the lyrics well part
of the lyrics are in french barber and
english
it's got a real good real good looking
female vocalist and then some dude and
she's usually like nude or half nude and
there's [ __ ] doing real good videos
tasteful kind of you know
um venus and furs type [ __ ] you know the
little [ __ ] black bobs and the
[ __ ] pvc corsets and
mixed their mix in classical music and
opera with with uh industrial and it's
good i liked it
good but they just uh it had that
looked like
those old italian
bondage cartoon or illustrated novels
don't talk about everything like that
motif yeah look good
midwest outlaw 420 says uh marilyn
manson is the king of the edgelords yeah
i agree like i said it's very very try
hard
and we've talked about this before but
when marilyn manson came out
um all like the real guys people were
like oh yeah here we go you look at that
now and there wasn't much to it
yeah
it's just the the mundanes i'm calling
the mundanes normies freak out over that
[ __ ]
but it was uh that was like lightweight
compared to like well i mean it had been
done yeah
like you know what i mean that's all it
was and like i said i'm not [ __ ]
it's like obviously everything's been
done but it's just kind of like
everybody like flipped out about it i'm
like yeah that's okay yeah die form had
been doing stuff like that better and
even classier than that for years
there was nothing and the music was
better a lot better it just wasn't
anything that's what i mean there wasn't
anything like was really original or
shocking although he was i liked his
covers
i did too i'll admit that yeah i'll
admit that
um you know i liked a couple of his
songs but i never bought any of his
albums or anything
uh gramther says question for both he is
who are your favorite faceless people in
your podcast chat room and why
we can't answer that because then
everybody will be like everybody's i
don't want to like play favorites yeah
if you're here right now if you're here
right now we love you okay that's like
such a diplomatic answer
i'm not going to like pick out anybody
in particular because then i would be
like what about me in a little stuff i
don't want to do that
um yeah camp guys talking about that
show fear factor i could never watch
that because it's like i don't mind
watching people do like
jackass type [ __ ] but
i have a real hard time watching people
eat gross stuff
like this one
we were it was i used to work in the
night shift and like when we were done
with work like sometimes we'd all just
like hang out like watch videos or
movies or whatever
and one of us um
my friend he picked fear factor and we
were watching fear factor and i remember
on this episode
somebody had to drink
a milkshake that had a big ass banana
slug in it
and
i saw about like [ __ ] no it was at in
there like they had it and i was like
watching that and i just like started
gagging and i couldn't stop and i was
just kind of like yep gotta leave the
room i can't watch people eat bugs or
slow factor yeah or snot or any or poop
or anything like that i just anything
like that i'm like nope i'm out i'm joe
rugged man he was a [ __ ] mastermind
for that [ __ ] but he's great she's so
dis that's just man
making people eat bull testicles see
that's what i mean i can't yeah
like i would rather if they gave me a
choice
if they gave me a choice they're like
look you can either eat like a handful
of cockroaches or
we're gonna like um i don't know like
pull out one of your teeth i'll be like
yeah pull one of my teeth out yeah i am
totally not eating no way no way yeah i
think one of them was a drink bull semen
too wouldn't it
yeah i think i saw that one yeah it's
like even thinking about it makes it a
hurdle and it was like a whole bunch of
it and you got a certain amount of money
if you could if you could finish it
or you know see that's what i mean if i
was on that show i'd be like i'd be like
you know what just hurt me yeah i'm not
i would rather
have you like break one of my fingers
than have to eat anything gross like
that and that is that is actually
legitimate yeah i remember
up at a damn um what do you call it
roulette table
and they had
some dudes and a couple of cute girls
and [ __ ] up there and uh they were
giving them 500
each for every one of these damn cave
spiders they would eat see that's not
enough money and she's [ __ ] picking
up that spider going
and it bitter on her [ __ ] lip and
[ __ ] because i'd already [ __ ] you might
as well eat it you know that kind of
[ __ ] and [ __ ] joe rogan back in the
day that was like the kind of dude to
talk your girlfriend into doing porn or
something he would sit there and just he
couldn't talk me into [ __ ] you just sit
there
talk these women into it it's psyching
them up and talking and it already
bitching you might as well eat it you
know just sit like that and eat they
would do it
you see the 500 see they can eat another
you ate one you could eat another one
and he [ __ ] talked about it and the
thing about it too is that one another
thing that bothers me that series again
one it's gross okay two
that spider isn't hurting anybody i like
spiders
i like slugs i'm like why would i want
to i'm not gonna yeah i don't want to
hurt him yeah and they were [ __ ]
funny looking they were real wide with
big long legs why would i want to hurt
him he didn't do anything to me making
money
i'm sorry that's not enough money
they're in there to make money they know
what fear factor was like i said i would
rather have them like break my pinky
nah then they they knew what fear factor
was then they put them in those damn
coffins and poor [ __ ] spiders on them
or see i don't mind that
yeah you would
no that's a no that does not bother me
at all
i'm not claustrophobic and i'm not
afraid of snakes you hear you'd hear
spiders you'd hear them say [ __ ] like
they poor
[ __ ] huge vats of [ __ ] roaches on
them and they would be like i can smell
them [ __ ] imagine that like not
roaches okay that's where i draw the
line but like i said i don't mind being
in a coffin i'm not claustrophobic um i
don't want to be buried alive okay but
i'll lay in a cough and have it closed i
don't know if that doesn't bother me
um
you can have rats run over me i don't
care about that you can have snakes run
over me i don't care about that you can
have spiders running me i don't care
about that no roaches though i don't
really like roaches but other than that
i would way way way rather do that than
have to eat something gross yeah that is
just like the last
i i would do almost anything on fear
factor before i would do that
like eat something really nasty like
that
and i know that's dumb i know it's like
a [ __ ] up thing but that's just my
thing
i don't i don't mind having like snakes
crawling all over that does not bother
me at all okay not at all go to the
restroom
so
but i'm not eating it i'm not eating a
slug i'm not eating spiders i'm not
doing it
i'm not drinking a big thing of [ __ ]
like i said even thinking about it makes
me want to [ __ ] throw up
uh yeah david june says would you rather
be in the saw type situation or beyond
fear factor well it depends on what the
saw situation was
um
if it was a saw situation where hey you
have a thing on your face and you just
have to like cut somebody's belly open
to get a key
i'd probably rather do that
that's terrible i'm like that's not that
big it's a big deal but it's not that
big i'm still not eating a roach sorry
like i said i'd pretty much rather do
anything than that it's just
like i said just thinking about just
thinking about that show with the
bananas like i'm just kind of like oh
it's just like making me feel so so
nauseated
it's just so gross and i don't know why
i don't know why
the thought of like eating something
gross is like so much worse for me than
anything else
i remember a few years back
because you know we have um
what you call uh universal studios and
they do halloween horror nights
and what they i don't know if they do
this anymore but they used to have a
couple houses where they're like oh well
we need somebody that will you know lay
in a coffin and have rats crawl all over
them and [ __ ] like that
and i used to think i was like you know
what that's
i don't know that just seems like it
wouldn't bother me it doesn't it rats
don't bother me i'm just not bothered so
i don't know so i don't know it's
i know other people would be bothered
and i'm not judging i'm just saying that
i'm not bothered by it
beezness says
my grandpa likes pig brains with
scrambled eggs yeah my grandma used to
eat that too and she was not from
lebanon she was actually from tennessee
um crampthers hammer said i once ate a
goat brain goat brain pita
at an arabic restaurant in dearborn
michigan it was rough
that sounds good
yeah i don't know like i said brain is
just fat
yeah my grandmother used to have she
used to like uh had cans of calves
brains and you scramble them with eggs
right
which you know i'm sure if you scramble
it with eggs it doesn't look like brains
anymore but it's like still
i don't know just why would you eat that
we have real food nowadays
you really don't have to eat that
anymore the only internal organ i ever
liked was that damn goose like goose
liver pate tasted pretty good
i'm not even really a big fan of that to
be honest with you
i love chicken hearts
but that's about it every now and then
yeah he's in a chicken every now and
then i can eat some fried
liver if it's done right
but most of the time it's not done right
but sometimes liver is a very very
strong you have to know how to cook
flavor yeah
i mean we've you've made like
gravy like thanksgiving time that had
liver in it yeah but you usually like
keep it on the dl because it's it it'll
really like overpower anything else if
you're not careful they just use just a
little bit
um yeah yeah german said if those
insects could speak they would all plead
for their lives
that's what i mean it's just it's kind
of like i don't know why
i don't know like i said i like spiders
i like slugs i can't the the thought of
just like killing it just for a stupid
like game show like really bothers me
insects are robots they don't i know but
it still bothers me like much less i'm
grossed out by the fact of eating it but
i'm just like
yeah but that doesn't mean anything to
me either i'm just kind of like why
would i kill it why would i why would i
want to kill it that seems dumb can't
stand them
it depends on what it is like i said i
don't like cockroaches yeah cockroaches
can [ __ ] off but
other than that i'm not really bothered
by any other and oh and like houseflies
can [ __ ] off but other than that
i don't want and mosquitoes can [ __ ] off
i'm not into [ __ ] scorpions although
i i use i don't wouldn't kill scorpions
just throw them out don't mind the house
or throw them out of the tank or
whatever
yeah i'm not
like i said i'm not and honestly i i
actually quite like spiders because
spiders will eat other bugs that i don't
like no i don't like them so
you know no they'll come and [ __ ] with
you they'll get in your house get in
your [ __ ]
we don't have that many spiders around
here
well not that many that get in the house
every now and then they do give
like i said only thing i don't i don't
really like cockroaches they can [ __ ]
off
uh beastness says tripe is big here aka
menudo
yeah
that's kind of a big thing
i just uh i don't know
business also said i randomly met an old
man here at a gas station and sat down
at my table and started talking to me
how he would drink a cup of his own piss
daily damn
we were talking about that the other day
because wasn't there a woman
on
was it my strange addiction
remember that [ __ ] my strange addiction
and she kept drinking piss yeah that was
some sex that was something sexual
though or something uh yeah probably
because why why on earth would you do
that i think we were thinking about that
the other day because i was thinking
about that couple that were super into
coffee enemas yeah
and uh oh i remember why because
because we were watching
rick sarah who is on
dan bell's channel all the time like
usually on another dirty room
he has his own
youtube channel
and he does a live stream he lives in
florida right he just like sits in his
backyard and like smokes a bowl and just
talks about [ __ ]
and he was doing a thing on the last
live stream where he had bought a whole
bunch of like those little enema bottles
and was
what was he doing exactly he was like
giving people people spiritual spiritual
issues
spiritual cleansings that's it called
spiritual cleansing
yeah
so because well for a second and i think
it looked like he was gonna stick that
[ __ ] up in his ass yeah and i think that
he did that on purpose
because because i'm like is he really
gonna
stick that up his butt right now okay
all you gotta do is just put your name
in the comment section and i'll give you
a spiritual clip
[Laughter]
and then he goes okay you know william
william brown she spreads
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure she's dead though good
idea
i'm just coming up with names
i just couldn't and it made me think of
like the coffee enema people from my
strange addiction although i have to say
i think
99 of the people on my strange addiction
are faking i don't know because i kind
of feel like i didn't say all of them
were yeah it's i think it's kind of a
situation like you know back in the 80s
and 90s when they had all these [ __ ]
talk shows
jenny jones and like [ __ ] geraldo and
ricky and all that uh and who who was
that other [ __ ] dude i can't remember
what his name was
um but i kind of feel like maury povich
that was that's what i was trying to
think of
though most of those people on there
were
actors yeah
they basically put out a call hey we
need somebody that will say that
they have sex with their
son or daughter
and you know go out and pimp them out or
whatever it's like whatever the topic
was it's like the more shocking the
better that's why the cops weren't and
waiting there that's what i mean because
it's like if those people were doing
half the [ __ ] they said on that show
they would so be under arrest i mean and
you could like catch them really easily
because you knew when the taping was so
it's like obviously they weren't really
doing most of that [ __ ] graham the two
girls one cup video was faked
that came out later
mm-hmm
that was a japanese thing they put some
something like pudding or something up
in some girl's booty and she squeezed it
out then they ate it but that it wasn't
it was i'm still not eating pudding out
of anyone's butt sorry they do [ __ ] like
that important all the time i know they
do but it's still gross so
that's that's what that was it wasn't it
was it was not scat it was fake skit
like i said still gross though yeah
because you're still putting [ __ ] it's
still you're still putting in your butt
and then like shooting it back out even
though it didn't originally come from
your butt right it was adulterated into
your butt yeah but
why don't you look at some girl's booty
if you look at some girl's booty anyway
and she's all cleaned it out they put up
there it's only for the americans
i mean they do they are pretty um
they're doing everything with i mean
they clean all those fingers and [ __ ]
you know licking booty fingers and [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] crazy licking booty
[Laughter]
get rid of that e coli warning they're
[ __ ] they're they're all [ __ ]
animated up and [ __ ] all kinds of
[ __ ] [ __ ] they put i would hope so
yeah they put all kinds of stuff in
there
man that's [ __ ] killed let's kill
bacteria and stuff they're professionals
yeah it's like we just
they have health regulations well unless
it's like some [ __ ] cheap jack kind
of [ __ ] porn yeah but i don't think
those exist much anymore well there's
homemade stuff but they probably know
what's up too
but i was kind of thinking to myself the
more i was thinking about that cup i
don't know why i'm so fascinated by this
couple that gives you look at booty
fingers that's going to be the next
this is that's what i'm going to call
this uh now i'm gonna call it the
licking booty fingers edition because
that probably won't get me demonetized
right yeah those individually aren't bad
words yeah
maybe i can spell it different
but uh i don't know why i'm so
fascinated by these coffee enema people
but
i think the reason i was fascinated by
them
was because one of the things that they
said
was that
one of them started out doing it and
then the other one was kind of like yeah
that's [ __ ] but then she was like no
i'm going to give you one and he's like
oh my god that's the best thing ever now
my ass is caffeinated so
caffeinated ass no that's what i'm going
to call it the caffeinated ass edition
and uh
so then they decided they were going to
give themselves coffee enemas so they're
like doing it like a whole bunch of
times a day
and i'm like are you telling me that
you're spending like literally
a whole entire essentially a whole
entire work day's worth of time sitting
around coffee up in your booty up with
coffee up in your butt like you have to
basically like lay around in your
bathroom like do you guys and they
showed them like laying in the bathroom
like sideways and then they're like
reading stuff on the tablet i'm like do
you guys get anything done are you just
like kind of [ __ ] late how can you do
that don't you get bored ridiculous okay
nobody wants coffee and they're about
that bad grandpa's asking me uh
about peter north as was peter all that
was all that [ __ ] faith from peter north
okay
those who don't know who he's talking
about there's a legendary male porn star
um [ __ ] i guess it was in the 90s
who uh he was
[ __ ] down the best looking women in
porn and [ __ ] he was just he was like
a muscle man type guy
and he was legendary for just [ __ ]
just i'm trying to say it politely
shooting the biggest ass loads you've
ever [ __ ] seen
okay that was kind of polite
[ __ ]
shooting lows for like [ __ ]
a whole [ __ ] 30 seconds
okay i you know i was [ __ ] watching
that you know as a kid i was like you
know that looks awful [ __ ] clear
okay
and uh not knowing anything about the
about you know
[ __ ] taking being on gear
if you're if you're not using stuff like
hcg
or
clomid
if you're on any anabolic steroids sperm
production will get shut down
um
in general it'll also [ __ ] stop the
other fluids somehow he was able to keep
seminal fluids going but there wasn't
any sperm
all right so it's just clear now maybe
he was faking it it might have been
urine
see because it would not be very
impressive in porn for a dude to shoot
blanks
there's nothing because there's no money
shot
so somehow he had to fake that
yeah and i
i think it might have been urine
or just
somehow he was able to take some kind of
drug
that didn't produce sperm but it did
produce some kind of seminal fluid it
was clear
there's lots of it
i don't think i've heard that guy's name
but i don't know if i've ever seen
anything he's a good looking muscle man
type guy
everybody liked him in porn the girls
all liked him he's a nice guy
but um i would say he was probably like
on
an avar and prima bowling probably based
on his build
and um that was in a time when they
didn't when they when guys that were
getting jacked like that would allow
themselves to uh
become um
what do you call it not sterilized but
uh
i guess it's like chemically castrated
you can rock up but you and you you
could reach orgasm but nothing would
come out
well there you go
yeah so somehow you had to fake that
so it wasn't what it appeared to be
midwest outlaw 420 says y'all talk about
porn while the comments are on about
gorvids
[Laughter]
yeah well i've seen a couple of those
too but i don't know that's not really
i don't know i'm kind of fascinated by
porn as a concept
i'm fascinated by what goes on on porn
sets and like i said i like all the kind
of like tricks
the tips and tricks yeah you know how do
we like achieve this effect and that
effect because you know it's a movie so
they're going to like do
fake [ __ ] when they can do it i'm sure
but that's just kind of like i don't
know it's like interesting couple really
good movies you want to see mope
mope was a really good one yeah we did a
review of that one and it's true story
and then there's that other one that was
pretty legendary boogie nights yeah
boogie nights
mope was kind of like the dark side of
that [ __ ] well boogie nights got pretty
dark too yeah because like i said that
was that was fictionalized but it was
kind of based on john holmes a little
bit yeah
um
mope was actually based on an actual
case like two guys that were actually
mopes in the sense that
they basically just like cleaned up porn
sets right no they were the
mopes were male
um
kind of like stand-ins in a way they
were kind of like uh
kind of the male version of a fluffer
would be eating a dude that just did
again to just jump in the middle of a
gang bang and like just like jerk off
yeah or something yeah they were kind of
like when they're doing like a whole
like circle jerk yeah they were kind of
like extras
like no name extras
they didn't get paid much money and i'm
giving her her little treats yeah she's
scratching on the box
they didn't get paid much money and
these two dudes wanted to be superstars
perform
male superstars of porn
which is in that industry was not
something that would happen
because you really couldn't build these
guys would not build you could not build
a loyal male fan base that would buy
videos over and over again based on
dudes
you know
very rarely now some dude who's
directing maybe
um
some guys had their own
their own lines uh one of them was that
dude that went to prison he had his own
line of videos
what was that fucker's name
they got him for obscenity he did five
years for that [ __ ] but what he was
doing [ __ ] they do it regularly now
uh what was that guy's name
max hardcore his name was max
stringer mr girl i don't remember
but the the name of the
name of his video series was max
hardcore for his name i remember that
yeah
and um yeah you can't get any of his
stuff anymore
because he just got banned banned from
everything and he got all his [ __ ] got
taken off the internet you're banned
from earth
yeah which is [ __ ] crazy because if
you were to see it alongside of
everything else that they're doing it's
like nothing it's the same well i kind
of feel like i mean nowadays they can
kind of get away with anything yeah
there's always like [ __ ] loopholes
and stuff well the jury decided it was
obscenity
i don't know man
well you know that was that whole [ __ ]
about well i remember all the kind of
crap that [ __ ] larry flint went
through back in the old days yeah
yeah like brought to court and all that
[ __ ] all and that was just like [ __ ]
hustler magazine it wasn't even [ __ ]
that was moving around that was like
[ __ ]
just still ass pictures
which is crazy
uh somebody asked about what a certain
what about a serbian film that's um i
saw that and it was just kind of like
i think i was expecting it to be it's
bad but i was expecting it to be way
worse than it was
it's a fictionalized movie it's about
it's kind of about like [ __ ]
that's enough film type of situation
yeah porn film type of thing yeah
but i don't know it's [ __ ] up but
it wasn't as [ __ ] up as i was
expecting maybe that means i'm jaded i'm
not really sure
you probably saw the mechanisms
mike uh mike says gotta watch house that
jack built that was a really good movie
actually i did a review that a little
while back
uh beezness says watch this behind the
scenes making a porn this one dude said
come on let's [ __ ] this [ __ ] and the
girl was like hey don't talk to me that
way yeah
i kind of hope most sets are like i'm
like man [ __ ] off
i'm gonna [ __ ] pet you if you keep
talking like that
uh what's the name of that movie yeah
mope m-o-p-e is the name of that movie
real good movie we just kind of came
across it at random just a random i
wanted to own it and put it on blu-ray
it's good it was like way better than i
was expecting it was way better than
this and it's this uh
about these are two real dudes it's
based on the real guys and everything
this black dude and a korean guy or a
chinese guy chinese-american guy oh i
can't remember yeah yeah there's an
asian guy yeah and there was nothing
physically impressive about these guys
at all they're evidently like they were
like really mediocre and they're trying
to make their own porn brand
and get out of this really shitty studio
that they worked for it was like bottom
of the barrel
and
they were kind of [ __ ] up the black
dude had some kind of schizophrenia or
mental
problem that over time
started it's kind of a sad story
but it's also kind of like a comedy but
it i think it like threads that needle
pretty well it's a sad story about these
two dudes who were really trying to be
famous in the porn industry
but there was mental illness involved
and a lot of failure involved and a lot
of [ __ ] uh fantasy like yeah these
guys had no chances of ever being a
stars but
they were hoping they were trying
and it didn't end well and like i said
you can't really fault them for that
it's like
but it was just kind of sad because they
had a completely unrealistic idea yeah
and expectations of yeah of what they
could actually accomplish they were
really into porn and they just thought
that they could be yeah
superstars yeah they thought that they
thought that they saw it as kind of like
a high art form and a form of
entertainment it can be
yeah but
they didn't have the talent to deliver
on that no
no okay and like i said that's what was
sad about it so in a way it's like it's
funny it's a hilarious movie it's like a
dark comedy yeah and it's true and it
goes and it's a true story yeah
but i don't know but but you still feel
like a lot of sympathy for them
yeah they were trying yeah
yeah camp guy says the porn industry now
is totally saturated no way to
differentiate your service i yeah i
could not i can't even think of a single
thing that you could do that would
make you stand out from because
everybody i mean everything's been done
yeah a million times over everything
everything's been thought of
um the money's not in porn anymore
the money's actually in those instagram
girls
yeah and you know those instagram
fitness girls and [ __ ] they don't
there's not even not even any nudity in
it they just post really cool pictures
and try to sell down protein powder and
creatine powder
and then they coach
girls or guys
online
and
some of these people of course you know
i guess they're infatuated with
with these instagram girls so
they'll spend thousands you know
hundreds of dollars a month on on their
services and their coaching
and if she has 20 guys that's a lot
yeah you know so
i don't think i don't know if they're
all guys probably some of them are girls
although i've heard and this probably
true that in the fitness scene
male coaches get mostly female students
okay
um
and it's because the average woman
doesn't want to be coached by a female
which that checked out in the horse
industry too
female trainers they could be as good
really really good female trainers don't
get very many students mediocre male
trainers they'll get a [ __ ] ton of
students make a whole lot of money and
the students don't even really progress
but that's not why those girls are there
they're just there to ride that ride a
horse around and look cool and be told
how cool you know how you know how good
they look on the horse they're not
really there to learn high level skills
it's just the ego stroking
so well we talked about that before i
said most of those
girls like particularly in the horse
industry they're not gonna like they
don't care about competing or anything
like that well they'll go to a show
but yeah but it's just like a hobby it's
not like i'm not gonna make a profession
out of it right they're not they're
they're they're not gonna go [ __ ] you
know it's just kind of like every kid
every kid that goes and does karate or
gymnastics doesn't want to go to the
damn olympics you know what i mean they
just it's just a hobby and it's fun yeah
you know what i mean and for some reason
they want a male trainer and he and if
he's cute that's even better then he'll
get a [ __ ] ton of them
because you know i mean i used to do
like ballet and gymnastics and
everything but i didn't want to really
want to do it for like professionally
ever it's just like the damn tiger scene
these dudes with tigers dude's got
tigers he's got a whole bunch of [ __ ]
girlfriends he's dressing them up in all
the costumes remember that [ __ ] tiger
cult
yeah it's the same thing
horses the horse situations are kind of
like that too
yeah because we've we've mentioned if
you if you guys didn't uh hear it on one
but one of the not not tiger king not
that guy
but and not the guy that was not that
other sleazy dude that was on the
documentary um but another guy that has
a bunch of big cats like that lives
right up the street from us like he has
like a big huge compound yeah like with
big huge like cement walls and stuff and
he's got all kinds of [ __ ] in there he's
got tigers lions i think he's got some
giraffes
um i think he's got some zebras in there
i've heard that he has
uh some gorillas maybe a lot of african
animals in there but he's a legal dealer
and all that stuff yeah it's like exotic
animals so if we ever have a really bad
hurricane and that wall blows down then
we're gonna have like all kind of
[ __ ] animals in our yard
that might be exciting
so one time we have like a big hurricane
and then like you look out the window
there's a big [ __ ] giraffe outside
yeah
that'd be [ __ ] hilarious but yeah
it's only like that's not even a mile up
the road it's like right there yeah it's
right there yeah it's no it's about two
miles yeah two miles okay that's not
that far i'm gonna go to the biker bar
on the way to the biker bar yeah i still
haven't gone to the biker bar i know
what'd you do at the biker bar yesterday
um
set up at the bar
let one dude ride my bike
oh i thought you were gonna say
something else no
let one dude ride my they [ __ ] like
that's how that's how these women want
to fantasize
now they [ __ ] pulled up [ __ ] one
of them was on a band of 1200 the other
one's on a harley and they're [ __ ]
looking at my [ __ ] fuel
i'm telling you man they're not fast
they're quick off the bottom
and because they have that harley
[ __ ] motor in there and they didn't
make that many of them [ __ ] it's kind
of a show stopper they should i'll be in
a [ __ ] parking lot full of [ __ ]
badass looking harley's they're looking
at my [ __ ]
oh what the [ __ ] is that it's bell drive
you know what
so
well you don't see them as often you
don't see them so i mean you see
harley's all the time you see them
looking at them you know what i mean
they'll come in and they go that's your
butt you know they come up to me that's
your that's your buell out there and
they start talking and they want to know
how fast it is can you keep the front
wheel down and blow this come on man and
now they'll follow you right out and
[ __ ] put them on it okay
no it's not not one guy's no no no no
no i don't want to i don't want to come
up underneath me i said dude
if you could ride that you will be able
to ride this don't worry about this
because no no not get off there and he
goes ah doggo the guy in the band he
took off with it because oh yeah this
thing's fun
but uh
yeah
what'd they put on the jukebox yesterday
oh what they have on there oh [ __ ] okay
you remember yeah i'm trying to remember
you were there
they had one song that was [ __ ]
totally ridiculous i had no idea who it
was it was like a joke song they played
that
they played [ __ ] free birds can be
played like [ __ ] five times of course
every [ __ ] night really got how long
how old is that song now i have a
million years old i think it's 73 right
was it free bird you gonna play that
okay so they're gonna play um
country music that i don't recognize
bob seeger they had that [ __ ]
oh we know how yeah i feel about it i
hate bob yeah tom has a very contentious
relationship on the road again here i am
uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] out of me it is depressing yeah
and then um
[ __ ] billy idol
they'll play billy well that's that's
exactly they'll play white red wedding
and they'll play rebel yell
and they'll play fresh flesh for fantasy
they'll put that on
wait everybody likes that one like that
has that video with all this like well
he writes yeah he writes so they'll put
it so that's allowed yeah he's loud
um
ac dc
they played uh okay that's awesome yeah
hell's bells they playing the hell's
best
and they played it i have a drink on me
there's another one and then the uh dj
maniac says that song's called turn the
page time to pee he says it's my karaoke
song but i but i do the metallica
version
when that song comes on like [ __ ] i'm
getting out of here
[Laughter]
oh i don't know if i'd go that far
to me i've heard it so many times
because like i said everywhere i worked
i'd rather hear [ __ ] jimmy buffett
no i i would hear [ __ ] well because
like i said everywhere i've worked
pretty much
um you know
most of the time i lived in daytona and
the only decent station that anybody
could agree upon was the hog which is
the classic rock station because at
least those songs you've heard them a
zillion times but at least you've heard
them so many times you can like tune
them out if they're annoying yeah
because nobody wants to listen to
country and that was pretty much the
only other station there was yeah so
so i've heard them so many times that
they don't even like really register as
music anymore it's just kind of like
part of like the background noise yeah
so they don't really like offend me all
that much they'll play some [ __ ] that'll
surprise me every now and then they'll
play something like slipknot that'll
come out yeah see that's the thing like
the classic rock station now has [ __ ]
from like the 90s
because that's old now
yeah well you know they're guys yeah
it's old they're guys in their 50s now
they put slip knot on there [ __ ] you
know
which is hilarious bikers in their 50s
will [ __ ] jam into that yeah because
yeah it's it's kind of like and then uh
you know it's funny to think about now
it's like nirvana but yeah
yeah
yeah that came out when i was like just
out of high school and then the real old
ones get pissed when that comes on oh
this is new [ __ ] and here's the thing
that jukebox you can talk to it through
your through an app on your phone yeah
so you can pay to move your song up
higher in the [ __ ] playlist
he says everybody being like a [ __ ]
they get a notification oh no yeah they
get a notification that he paid
i'm putting
up above your head and then it's and
then you have a way to [ __ ] counter
bid
for another 20 for another [ __ ] 25
cents you can move yours back up into
the front line so they start [ __ ]
with each other you [ __ ] you ain't
making me pay five dollars to play that
song
you ain't let ain't at five dollars that
damn song
you know that's what they're doing oh my
god that's fighting over who's gonna
[ __ ] and the sad thing about it is
they probably have the eight track at
home
oh jenny just threw some shade no i'm
just
well that's the thing this is the thing
that always used to like freak me out
whenever i you know wherever i used to
work and they always played uh you know
the classic rock station and there was
always people that called in to request
like you know hey play free bird i'm
like dude do you not have the record i
don't just listen to whatever you want
yeah go on youtube and listen to it it's
free what who the [ __ ] calls into like a
[ __ ] radio station
nowadays
and requesting free bird yeah
i kind of feel like if you're gonna go
to all the trouble to call a radio
station request a song at least request
something they don't play they're not
gonna play like that hour again anyway
you know what i mean they're gonna play
free bird eventually they play it like
twice an hour
um just wait just sit tight and they're
gonna play it uh you don't gotta call
seriously or like i said just go to
youtube like a normal person and listen
to it any goddamn time you want to
i don't think what else is then uh
we gotta go we gotta go down there like
on a sunday
sunday afternoon well maybe we can go
this sunday all right tomorrow i wanna
go see antlers okay we're going on a
sunday sunday afternoon sunday we can go
um i'll go and you you know you can
either ride on the back i'll put the
passenger pegs on or i have to go in my
car he's he's embarrassed to be seen
but it's called the oasis i would never
go to the ocean
in a cage because it's going to be
[ __ ] two wheels man
is everybody gonna get on my case
because because i just came in a car no
no half the people and you didn't come
like and i didn't come on the back of
your no i'm not doing the old lady [ __ ]
i'm not no i have to no but
you can only ride up there really on the
tail
if we were on a cruiser you're not
really supposed to do that on a [ __ ]
little i've ridden on the back of your
build before and it's fun but it's also
terrifying yeah
um you know so my suspension really
isn't set for it it's not yet it's not
it's not ideal it's got a little short
tail it's only and the whole time i'm
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna fall off and like
buzz my head i'm sitting on a [ __ ]
little tail that's maybe about it it's
like that yeah
and my ass is like too big for that
situation a little bit
everything's all tucked up too big for
that situation so um
it's just
but uh it's it's
sunday afternoon you know people
everybody's riding and they got their
they got their mamas with them or their
old ladies and all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're dressed up and [ __ ] a lot of
weird different kind of biker outfits
like uh there was some up in there in
their 70s
type [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
with the bell bottoms and [ __ ]
bikini tops with [ __ ] vests over it
you know that kind of [ __ ] wow that's
old school the more yeah they were doing
that and dude had [ __ ] long hair they
just have their own each one everybody
kind of has their own little thing going
on depending on who they are if they're
wearing colors they gotta [ __ ]
leave the colors outside so because
there are gags that show up but they
fold their [ __ ] up put it on the seat
we'll see that's what i love
that happens in daytona too yeah all of
the biker bars say well except for like
the really scuzzy ones yeah i have the
signs out front okay so they hang them
up on the bikes but they're not fighting
each other yeah yeah and then um i mean
everybody all know each other just have
a beer chill out yeah and then um
when there's a lot of women in there the
the bartenders act up a lot they act up
a lot that's when they start [ __ ]
popping titties out and [ __ ] you know
and then they're get into titty
competitions and [ __ ]
yeah they're gonna challenge you
so i'm gonna have to get in a titty
fight you might have to get a titty
fight
[Music]
they're gonna drop them back
i'm gonna have to start slapping
they start challenging one another there
can there be only one there could be
only one
i think i'm gonna win well i don't know
i haven't been down there i haven't been
down there but i still think i'm gonna
win the bartender the bartenders are all
late 40s or well so am i yeah yeah
they're all our age so they're all
afraid so they're not really they're not
youngsters
and they're
biker friendly or biker they're biker
wobbles
tom's gonna like he's gonna get really
drunk and then he's gonna like
cough up a bunch of money like trying to
get me to like chest bump some other no
chick with it yeah i can see i'd see how
it's gonna go i didn't get that [ __ ] on
video that's what i'm saying yeah this
is what he always kind of hopes will
happen
i've seen that [ __ ] happen live that's
true yeah i've seen this happen i've
been pretty drunk too with it yeah
[Laughter]
yeah puerto rican biker girl in there
[ __ ] she was about 55 [ __ ]
twerking and [ __ ]
and her [ __ ] husband was next to her
and it's [ __ ] funny you just gotta be
there
to understand it
and they're playing that [ __ ]
ridiculous music i call it ridiculous
music because it happens she just
[ __ ] thinks
it's it's just like something out of the
movies i want to get a video i'll show
we'll show it on the show
well you know like i said it's not i
don't know it's ridiculous to us because
it's like even nowadays like i'm i'm old
like i consider myself an old person but
even
even now that's like [ __ ] my like dad
was listening to yeah
so that's like that's that's old even
for me the oasis is from the 1950s yeah
and that place was built and it was a
gas station originally and it was it is
it's very small and it was turned into
and now it gets it's cool it looks small
it looks small for the front but there's
actually more than you think
and um
the parking lot goes all the way around
you can't get in there in a weekend
just yeah i imagine well there's not a
lot around here like [ __ ] cameras
everywhere it's got more cameras in the
inside of a bank
[ __ ] man yeah so you know [ __ ] goes down
in there on the weekends oh i'm sure
they say there's fights going on in
there every weekend so
i don't think i'll be going over there i
think they need like patrick swayze to
go in there and like sort that [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
there's something
between between between all of them
they're sorting it out on their own
straight justice
oh my god yeah all right talk some more
about that uh because i have to go to
the bathroom all right also my drink's
empty but don't get a drink at the same
time i'm in the bathroom because then
nobody will be here and that would be
really weird i don't care you don't care
they just sit there and just look i'll
put i'll put the down music on
put that damn music on let's let's see
what uh let's see what dj maniacs say
dj said all acdc songs sound exactly the
same they do but they also all sound
pretty good
there's some just i don't know ac dc is
just kind of like it's generic it's just
generic australian
[ __ ]
power metal i guess
you know i mean i'm not sure it's metal
i guess it's metal
it's really really hard rock
it's got it's got guitar solos so i
guess it's metal
but yeah it does kind of sound like a
formula
it's still good though
it's just kind of
drinking music
everything is about drinking drinking or
having sex
yeah drinking and [ __ ] that's what
it's about
it's that much
there's not much to ac dc but they were
good all the way back to the bon scott
days you know i like brian johnson too
he was good you know just
there are many bands that survive that
survival
yeah there are many bands that
successfully survive losing their
their their lead singer although it's
not all that common i mean i do kind of
feel like it's not that common what's
that
a band losing their lead singer and then
still being like equally successful
afterwards it's
it does happen but i don't know who did
it
all right babe ac dc did it
mike says over 70 is the new old school
well it's it's weird because
i don't know like i said i guess because
i grew up in daytona which has like a
really big biker culture so
even when i was a kid
you had
like what you're talking about that
sounds like [ __ ] that was going on in
daytona when i was a kid and it's like
funny that it's still going on
and it's probably like the same people
those dudes are still in there that's
what i'm saying it's like the same
people i got i got into kind of like a
like a friendly fight with the old man
that was next to me he got
he goes ah and he's talking in the
middle of it you know he's like how old
are you and i said i'm 53 and he goes
you're young you're still young i said
how old are you because i'm 61 and i
said you're a [ __ ] baby i'm a what
you're a [ __ ] baby i have a wife i'm
a baby
yeah you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm 62 years
old how am i [ __ ] baby since you're a
[ __ ] baby that's young that's nothing
then he goes well if i'm baby where does
that make you
and i said i ain't even born yet
and he's like yeah
that's the thing about it they're all
just
they're all like that yeah just yell at
them
yeah that's fine i don't i don't have a
problem with that yell at him
you're a [ __ ]
baby yeah you're a baby
probably good to yell at him because
most of them probably can't hear
anything like no shame i can't hear
either so
it's just it's weird because
getting old is so weird
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
either but it's like it's weird because
and i've heard this from other like
really old people that are just kind of
like yeah i don't feel like an old
person i'm like yeah i kind of no
i mean i'm sure like really young people
look at really old people and they're
like what you're gonna ride it out to a
doc yeah you are like really old but you
don't feel like an old person yeah
sometimes you do so there's this uh look
okay i think i got zach on here i'm
gonna show you zach
there's a um a old bodybuilder
from the old internet back in the 90s i
remember him his name was scoob went by
named scooby
and scooby was one of the first
online internet
coaches lifted he was a muscle dude he
got driven off the old internet because
it came out that he was gay and married
to some dude
so some of the other fitness guys
started [ __ ] with him and they drove
him off the internet he finally came
back
the name's scoob scooby scooby's on um
he's on youtube again and he's up in
germany right now
and he just put out a video two three
days because it says 60 is the new 30.
he's like 60.
he looks pretty good for 60. he looks
pretty uh pretty good for 60.
um
you can tell he's been on those
androgens since he was a young man he's
kind of his skin kind of looked a little
bit worn out but he's
got a i mean he's [ __ ]
light years ahead of the average guy in
his 60s
and um i don't i think i don't think
he's with that dude anymore
he's just down in germany
being one of them bdsm [ __ ] power
bottoms i guess you know cruising dudes
in germany
and he does look like
some dude that would do well in the
german german uh [ __ ] power bottom
scene or something you're kind of a
fetish type of guy scooby check him out
yeah but he's got a real good way with
uh
people
you know he's got a real kind of
nice
sounding voice and [ __ ] and he's like
you see the problem is with a lot of
young guys is that they grow up scrawny
and weak and have a poor self-image and
poor
poor self-esteem and no confidence and
if we get them trained up and get them
bigger and looking good then they'll
feel better about themselves that's why
scooby talks feel better about
themselves and they won't have all these
you know problems with depression and
they won't have all this problem for
drug abuse and then they can go out and
find girls or guys whatever they want
and yeah and he's just uh scooby was
kind of like a motivational speaker i
like scooby and [ __ ] uh yeah i didn't
like the fact that they drove him off
the internet back in the day yeah he's
back you know i mean
that was other muscle dudes that did
that you know i mean trying to shame him
and [ __ ]
that seems a little weird because i do
kind of feel like there's always in the
in the kind of muscle head yeah yeah
like there's no gaze right what the [ __ ]
and it's just that seemed like
protesting too much okay it's like
everybody knows yes yes i think i was
thinking the same thing i was like
everybody's acting like outraged now
because he was just like open about it
and i'm like come on you guys yeah just
come on yeah knock it off i mean because
like [ __ ]
even arnie and some of those [ __ ]
interviews and [ __ ] he's there with
the other [ __ ] dudes like you know
franco colombo and [ __ ] these dudes are
[ __ ] champions in there and they will
be like wait a minute there's gays in
bodybuilding what what
what really you know [ __ ] now i was
always there i mean i kind of i kind of
feel like that was
going back to like a long time ago going
back to the 40s and 50s yeah before it
was really mainstream i kind of feel
like that was like a large part of the
appeal of it yep yep
back in the 40s and the 50s
and you can go back and [ __ ] uh uh
listen to the work of leroy
leroy colbert who was a chant one of the
first
black bodybuilders to ever be on the
cover of a muscle magazine he was uh
kind of adopted by [ __ ] um uh was it
joe weeder i think it was joe weeder one
of the guys that um
that started a gold's gym
and almost kind of adopted him as a son
and when they were in the 50s
those dudes made money
doing photo shoots and selling nude
photos
to admirers they just said admirers yeah
that's what i mean they were men yeah
like nobody it wasn't super open but
everybody knew what was going on we all
knew what was going on sure
yeah like i said someone was heavily
kind of controlled so it just seems like
really disingenuous to like turn around
and be like oh like shun the gay one i'm
like come on now
those dudes if by mostly
those dudes weren't gay
and they weren't as far as i know gay
for pay what you'd call it but they all
had guys that were sponsoring their
careers sure to pay gym fees to pay
the drugs that they need to help pay
this and that and of course
your sponsors
got good photo shoot photos
okay you read in between the lines there
of course you know we know what you're
talking about
we don't know how explicit they're
talking about so that's just leaked it's
just kind of like art photos black and
white art photos and you know nudes
but there's probably all kinds of stuff
out there when you have to think too
particularly back in that time period
and even nowadays uh women aren't going
to pay for that um
women wouldn't pay for it like i said
even now i don't think and even now it's
probably more common than it used to be
but i kind of feel like even back in the
day like women didn't really pay for
porn it because they don't
it's not like like i said it's not
something that's ingrained in them
women like women like erotica yeah
you know what i mean generally not not
always obviously there's like a lot of
variation there but
the guy who came up with the uh with
bodybuilding the first modern
bodybuilder of the of the late 1800s
he was the one that proved that the
greek statues
were not idealized statues that those
were real people that
the greeks and the romans
actually did lift weights
and he replicated those bodies
he took the dimensions and he scaled
them all down and he started looking
that way you can google him eugene
sandow
and uh when you win
um
olympia they give you the sandow trophy
or sandow award it's a statue of eugene
sander with your eugen santa with a
big old barbell
and uh
his wife uh
wouldn't eventually had some kind of
fallen out wouldn't let him back into
the house and just treated him like a
scumbag and he kind of lived on his own
for the rest of his life
he did something immoral we don't know
exactly what it was
but it is known that he gave private
showings
private viewings
he would do muscle routines and a strong
man act and if you paid extra money
select men
and he did have a ladies night too but
certain select guys would be able to see
him more up close and personal we were
these were nude
okay it hadn't been what they're talking
about and there were some nude selfies
and [ __ ] type photographs that he would
sell
and it's
been wondered maybe if he was uh
also bisexual and probably like you know
having sex with some of these dudes and
they think his wife found out
and that was just back in the day so
it could be
it's not official but it could be that
the the father of modern bodybuilding
was bisexual
yeah it may have been like i said no one
no one knows for sure but for sure i
mean it sounds i think yeah it sounds
kind of likely probably i think he was
uh
hooking on the side and it was really
not it's sad because it really wasn't
all that acceptable back then he was it
was it was
the problem was that he was married yeah
and his wife [ __ ] got pissed
which yes you know i i can see that but
not so much being bisexual but just kind
of like the whole
you know doing [ __ ] behind
uh yeah victor says it feels weird that
we're getting old and watching everyone
get old too
like david arquette looks old as [ __ ]
all of a sudden in the face he does um
because i just saw i hadn't seen him for
a really long time and then i saw him in
the trailer for the new scream and i was
kind of like oh yeah he looks old now
i'm just so used to seeing him in the
original screen from 1996. we'll go back
to what me and bees nests were talking
about
spend the money
use modern technology
for life extension do
do your [ __ ] hormones
you will thank me later
karen rob says i'm 62 but inside i'm 36
so odd yes i'd like to see your blood
work
it's the same kind of thing i'd like to
see you please and dermot says i'm 55
and it feels like only yesterday that i
was falling out of clubs at 6 00 a.m
yeah
we still kind of do that again
but uh you know but it's just the only
difference is it takes a couple more
days to recover yeah it used to be i
could go to work the next day now
now i still can but i'm just i'm not
happy about it
yeah oscar says did you guys see antlers
yet unfortunately a friend told me it
was bad but victor said uh i thought it
was pretty okay yeah i actually want to
go see it tomorrow so we'll see is there
any more like is there any more oh yeah
yeah
you forgot you got so excited about
muscle men that you've got to make me a
drink see how she's coming well hey
i'm just i got i call it like i see it
you want the same thing yeah let me go
see if there's any more ice out of them
yeah we got to check the ice because i
don't know if
somehow the ice maker got turned off
the little bar
so it wasn't making ice all night so we
didn't have ice today
uh mike says all this drinking does not
hold all the answers to this life all it
does is give you a moment's rest from
what haunts you deep inside isn't that
all that really matters though i'm not
honestly looking for any answers because
i don't think there are any um
you know i'm just kind of looking to
have a good time is what i'm looking to
do
because that's really
that's really where it's at
just like
trying to like trying to like pick out
some enjoyment a little bit of fun
just trying to relax every now and then
that's pretty much all i'm doing
although you know i try to drink like
too much anymore because then like
tomorrow i'll be like man yeah it'll be
awful but
what are you gonna do
uh victor says i'm not against getting
brotox
i never heard that term but that's
pretty [ __ ] awesome
like a brotox
is there was there any ice that was a
little bit okay
what
goodness gracious
what are you calling me for pokey
yeah
what's up what is it that's her little
what's with it yeah that's her little
come on
come on
she can't get down on the floor
well i did earlier and she was just like
all kind of excited yeah she was just
kind of like
yeah she likes to go get all up in my
hair for some reason she was like super
into my hair let's get down on the floor
with her yeah she's not
that's the thing she'll sleep in a chair
by herself
but she's not a lap cat like she won't
jump up in your lap and fall asleep
beijing will sometimes thank you
but
pookie actually pookie wants you to come
down there
she's like no i want you down here on
the floor and play with me that's how
that goes she's like you have to come to
me
um
victor says jenny you got a great radio
voice thank you
i just got delilah flashbacks delilah
fixture called it brotox
have you ever heard that
who
i said victor just called it brotox
what's a botox oh you know what i mean
get it oh like botox yeah
beezness says gotta go guys see you next
time all right man bye gotta hit up
mcdonald's get it that does actually
kind of sound kind of good there's not
really a mcdonald's very close to here
is there
now that i'm thinking about it karen
says tom your arm's looking so good
thank you baby i'm gonna be leveling up
here in a bit
can you see the vascularity
oh god
i'm going to be getting like
i'm probably going to be
getting another three four pounds of
muscle over here in the next couple
months
about another three pounds probably on
the arms
yeah
oh [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
like a beast
that's that beast are you gonna are you
gonna do something like are you gonna
dragon are you gonna do some naked lots
of dreams some naked
[Laughter]
i put my boots up on your [ __ ]
shoulder and you take a picture and
that's it and i'd be like all nausea
like
my foot up on the bike like that [ __ ]
dick falling and getting
getting burned on the [ __ ] exhaust
pipe and [ __ ]
getting stuck at the spokes yeah
[ __ ] that's not funny i had my [ __ ] i
had my [ __ ] calf burned by a
motorcycle tailpipe when i was a kid
that just i had a scar for like years
and years from that
tom actually showed a good amsr voice
last year i'm not sure exactly i don't
remember exactly what i was doing yeah
what did you say now i can't remember
like i kind of remember you doing that
but yeah yeah i make all kinds of books
you should get like right up to the to
the microphone and you could do like all
the
people
you could do all kind of like sexy yeah
oh maybe maybe it was when we were
talking about um
when we were talking about dan bell
doing like quiet time yeah because i
think you said
that you said the same thing that danbot
says a little bit of some quiet time i
think we could all use a little we can
all use just quiet time that's what he
says
i think we could all use a little
quieter you got to get in there you got
to get in the uh
character for that [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
i'm gonna do that [ __ ] msr i just
took a sit like this i have a [ __ ]
crown on my head
[Laughter]
thank you my lady
yes
yes my lady can you kneel before you're
king
[Laughter]
the name of my amsr channel is i am your
king
yeah well there you go that's a
brilliant idea yeah i am your king and
i'll be brilliant and i have the damn
you know like the [ __ ] cape with the
[ __ ] herman [ __ ] trim and a
[ __ ] you can do some fabio [ __ ] do
some fabio [ __ ] a ball fabio fabio bald
fabio
just don't get hit in the face by a bird
i'm just saying
poor fabio
[Laughter]
you know that's not butter
that's right i forgot he was in those
wait was it i can't believe it's not
butter is that the commercial
you know that's not the butter oh my god
yeah
now i kind of want to watch those on
youtube is that [ __ ] up
that's i'm gonna go down some kind of
[ __ ] rabbit hole about that
that [ __ ] was on all this [ __ ]
romance novel
covers back in the day
he's totally like he's not my type
though yeah
i don't really like that like
i don't know
i don't know it's just not my thing i
guess all right now the gays are jumping
on me
[Laughter]
sherman says i'm gay for pay victor
garcia says i'm gay for pay gay for
barter gay for free
that's all right
victor's just gay for free
go ahead
go ahead dermott
he's got you victor's got your name
written all over you
this is a [ __ ] power bottom man all
you gotta do is just lay back put your
arms on your head he jumps up in the
[ __ ] air comes down on your ass first
no lube needed he's self-lubricating
modern he brings his own trampoline
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know your life it's
like landing ass first on a fire plug
[Laughter]
you're talking about all this and you
don't have your [ __ ] sucker head on i
don't have a [ __ ]
hold on or even your sexual trainers are
happy there's some [ __ ] to be sucked
around here
i'm not sure i like it at that rakish
angle you might want to like put it back
yeah i gotta be [ __ ] policeman victor
says i'm a top bro my type is 23 year
old latinas okay
man let me [ __ ] let me spin my own
[ __ ] fantasy yarn for the
people out here okay
i don't i don't mean to misgender you
okay
you [ __ ] top that you're a top
okay that's it for the hat really i'm
gonna put your section
[ __ ] sexual tyrannosaur hat
yeah what did i say i was gonna call
this video caffeinated ass
don't know what it is the coffee anime
edition
i'm gonna go in there and get some more
eyes
really
why didn't you bring some more up in the
in the cooler things i didn't bring my
thing down there no the bridge oh i
didn't
i know there's not enough ice in that
bend to put into put a dent in it like
we even have like a little a little
cooler that we bring up so we don't have
to go all the way down to the
refrigerator one of these days
we're going to get a mini fridge and put
in here
yeah mini fridge
and then i can put like a couple of ice
trays
in the freezer thing we should have it
like it's a hotel room because i'm like
too lazy to walk down the stairs and get
the ice out of the [ __ ] tree
do you know there are so some whole
entire days that i
don't ever go downstairs isn't that
funny
uh dermit says i'll take whatever i
could find these days
i mean you know
that's like i said no shame
you gotta do what you gotta do
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
damn
ugh
what the [ __ ] else what is what the [ __ ]
else is going on
yeah
that's what yeah that's what he was
doing he was doing the damn bell
impression
that was like super funny
man it's i i don't know i don't know why
i love dan bell
um and like i said he was kind of like
out of commission for a little while
like he was gone for six months
and then when he came back like he said
he'd been having like a lot of uh mental
health issues and stuff like that but he
actually looks a lot better he looks
like
he's lost some weight
looks like he's kind of
cleaned himself up a little bit he's on
like some different medication
and uh he seems to be like in a lot
better
uh mental place which i thought was kind
of nice
but
yeah it's funny because
we watch him so sometimes we get like
the recommendations for rick sarah's
stuff too and like rick sarah is totally
funny because
if you've ever seen another dirty room
like rick sarah is just like completely
totally and utterly shameless like he'll
just do anything
um
like like not even hesitate
so he has his own kind of charm i've
heard they have a
podcast that
um i think they put up one a week but
you can only listen to them if you are
on their patreon i think you have to be
like a five dollar a month subscriber
and i've heard a couple of them just you
know they put up a couple every now and
then just like for a sample and they're
[ __ ] hilarious they just do it's kind
of [ __ ] like this where they just like
sit around and like smoke pot and drink
and just like talk about a bunch of
gross [ __ ]
and um and they're really really funny
uh so i'll have to do that but i don't
know i kind of feel like
the funny thing about rick and it's that
he i think he has a little bit i don't
know i i feel like he has like a little
bit of resentment because dan bell has
like how many million subscribers
and
rick is kind of like so he's always kind
of like uh
he's always kind of saying kind of stuff
like
you know dan has all these subscribers
but i i wish like all dance subscribers
would come over and subscribe to my
channel and see yeah right but they
never do and he's always kind of like it
is just kind of like
it sounds like really desperate but it's
also like super funny so it's just like
every time he starts doing that i'm like
oh
i don't know and he was talking about
it's not just dan it's that other guy
too that has bright sun films
uh jake williams who also has his own
channel because uh he produces some of
the dance videos he's like yeah and jake
williams has x amount of subscribe i
don't really know how many subscribers
that they have but he's always like
keeping track of how many subscribers
they have and it's like he doesn't have
as many and he just like gets bummed out
about it like nobody loves him as much
as those two but it's just like i don't
know that's really cool that's really
funny to me
what you're doing pope jesus oh
you're excited about being here you want
to be on the show look at your big eyes
yeah oh
yeah what are you doing what are you
doing
don't you chew on that
i know what you're thinking yeah and she
knows that she knew that you knew what
she was thinking about because that tell
what shut up yeah
did you see the tail yeah shut up she
knows what i'm saying yep she doesn't
i'll chew on it if i want to
okay come here although she'll she'll
chew on it if she thinks that i'm not
looking or i'm not paying attention
because as soon as i say don't chew on
that she's always like well i wasn't
chewing on anything i don't know what
you're talking about
grab this i've bought that uh
i bought a uh that lotion or that ocean
um
uv
uv 9g radio
and it came with a little rubber ducky
type antenna on there
and i didn't know it was in my pistol
belt
and i had that thing underneath the
little cubby in the nightstand next to
next to the bed
and she was climbing up there in the
middle of the night and chewing on the
end of that damn
antenna yeah she's a chewer i pulled it
out man there's all these little teeth
marks on it god damn
brand new radio
so i ordered another one they were like
10 it was only 10 bucks for the for the
antenna put the new one on put it right
back in there and i caught her going in
that thing again oh i forgot i [ __ ]
and she's when i pulled her out she had
her mouth on the end of it
she's like oh a new one and she's gonna
chew on that oh boy yeah it's brand new
fresh new toy for pokey freshened it up
so i pulled it out and what i did was i
took the brand new one and i stored it
to put the old one back on
put the old one back on and i just
wrapped it with that
stick that that that grip tape that he
put on um badminton rackets and [ __ ]
tennis racks oh yeah yeah sometimes you
can use it for gun parts and [ __ ] where
you're gonna get make something kind of
feel a little bit better
so i had that wrapped around there like
that so that's just that i got another
thing that i want to do when i when i
start my own channel
i'm gonna do a combo section stop it
pokey
i bought one of those
twenty dollar
twenty five dollar
[ __ ]
baofeng
uv five r's
and i like that little radio for the
money that thing's [ __ ] great
real good
a lot of features learning [ __ ] how
to do chirp
there's so many tutorials on it though
and i'm getting that that's paramilitary
[ __ ] but anyway uh
you gonna give her some of those or i
got they're there on the ground oh okay
well you have to point them at her
because i think she forgets they're
there right here
right here
that's the same ones that's in the box
right there
that's the same ones that's in the box i
promise actually it isn't but she i get
i give her that
oh she's mad she's mad yeah
[Laughter]
with that uv 5g i'm gonna get a couple
more of those at that price and a whole
bunch of them a whole bunch of them
extra batteries
but what we were going to say is that
the thing about pookie is one she likes
to chew on everything she's a chewer
um
but she doesn't like to chew on things
that she's supposed to chew on
because she chews on [ __ ] so i bought
her like a whole bunch of like chicken
flavored chew sticks and like little
chewy things with catnip on them and
stuff does she ever chew those no
she pushes him off the table and like
looks at him
but
if you it's like if it's like a cord or
like a metal thing or like a table leg
she's just like all over it she only
likes to chew things if she's not
supposed to chew them
but uh oh now she's all bummed out
does she have any treats over there
she's eating them oh okay
she scratches on those boxes
uh i guess elsa's out now but she yeah
elsa sent us those two big
boxes of treats
and when she wants one she just goes up
to and goes
until you open it and then you pour him
out and then she just like looks at you
like
okay
zach says uh it's talking about dan bell
didn't he get divorced and broke up with
his boyfriend after that within a few
months of each other now see where did
his little boyfriend go because i kind
of feel like
they did some videos together but then
he's still at the belvedere right like
he got rid of his office but he still
has the apartment there and he's talking
about how he wants to move out
but i guess his boyfriend isn't there
anymore so i just moved out does he have
a new one he's got that new one now see
i thought the new one was our it was
also gone because he hasn't talked about
him like the last couple live streams
i've seen i saw livestream two days ago
and he didn't mention him all right
and he wasn't there sometimes he's on
the show but i know like his boyfriend i
can't know what his name is but um
but he doesn't like to be on camera like
he'll let his voice be on camera like
he'll be on the other side but he
doesn't like to be on camera
um
but i haven't like he hasn't been on
there for a little while so i don't know
they were living together but i don't
know if he's gone now and then zach said
i really miss will krapinsky too yeah i
do too and honestly i really like
i like the trio from another dirty room
i like dan and rick
and brandon
those three are super funny together
and like they'll go in that hotel room
and they'll get like really really drunk
and rick will get like really [ __ ] up
on weed
and drunk
and they will just do all kind of like
crazy [ __ ] and rick will just like eat
anything well rick's like some kind of
sanitation guy or something or a health
inspector he used to be a health
inspector he's retired but he used to be
going there with all these little test
strips and check
see how much bacteria is on [ __ ]
like i said his big thing now i don't
know how this got started but he started
um
eating
the bars of hotel soap and like giving
his opinion about which ones taste
better than other ones and it's like
that got to be a thing so now he kind of
has to do it like every single time
which
okay okay so um if you guys have any
questions if you want us to discuss
anything or talk about anything
everything is on the table it's open
lines friday man we'll talk about and
we'll talk obviously because we've
already talked about all kind of like
talking about so much [ __ ] i'm fine
brad jones says just got off work yay
for 13 o'clock yeah yeah sorry i'm late
hey everybody
uh you know you're not late it's just
kind of like
what time is it
it is seven
yeah it's very it's very early i mean
it's friday night for christmas
um
huh
okay now stay still that's still that
yeah you're good
he says now i'm kind of sad because the
podcast roger deacons and his wife do is
going on hiatus because they're making a
new movie with sam mendy's yeah let's
talk about grits says victor oh [ __ ]
i haven't had any grits in a really long
time you haven't made any grits aren't
in season
i thought you said that they were always
in season
i remember you saying i could make
something many times i could make some
i'm just saying those a lot of carbs it
is well that's probably why we haven't
eaten yeah that's a lot of carbs that's
probably why we've been kind of on a
diet
but um kind of well i mean you know
we're kind of like trying not to do too
much carby kind of [ __ ]
although
shrimp and grits sure does sound good it
does on that's another thing we haven't
even eaten at like chantals for a really
long time yeah
well we haven't been over there in a
while
we were what was the last time we were
at mannequins yeah what was the last
time we were at mannequins was like two
or three weeks ago yeah and we didn't
eat there
yeah we just i we either didn't eat on
the way home or we stopped at ihop kind
of got getting mad at chantal's because
when you go down there late after the
club um service takes forever depending
on who's working
but uh
because there's never anybody in there
it's always so it's always kind of like
really slow because i mean
on paper they're open until 4am
but
if there's only like one table of people
in there which there usually only is
because the weird thing about downtown
sanford
is that almost all of the bars
close
at
11.
yeah which is very strange but i think
that's maybe why because that's
i don't know that's really weird because
normally most bars downtown orlando
stuff like that are open until 2 33.
um so
the fact that pretty much everything in
sanford i guess it's some kind of like
city regulation but mannequins gets
around it because they're up until what
2 30. is she doing it
oh goodness gracious poke she's flying
through the air
she's in the lane flying through the air
position yeah okay
you flying pokey she's like shut up stop
knocking away
why is it weird why
um
have you ever listened to the well
there's your problem podcast or watch
fascinating horror i don't think so
but
those are ones i'll look up like i said
i have so many [ __ ] youtube shows and
podcasts and stuff like that i'm like
there's so many i want to listen to but
i feel like i don't have time
victor says i still haven't tried grits
that's why i wanted to talk about them
well like i said where you live man you
kind of have to know how to make them
because like i said if you just eat them
plain then they're gross yeah but gotta
know what to do with them because well
they're not gross they just don't really
taste like anything yeah they're kind of
or they're just bland i mean i don't
know where you live
but you could probably get instant grits
that are already already kind of have a
little bit of flavor in them they're
settlement packets sometimes depending
on where you live
quaker
instant grits some they're coming they
come in packets like those little
oatmeal packets
and just that's the easiest way
and some of them come pre-flavored it's
not great but
they're acceptable but you have to like
adulterate them i mean you have to put
like half a stick of butter in there and
no not a stick come on well i'm just
saying split some butter and then
crumbled up strips of [ __ ] bacon in
there oh cheese
slices of american cheese or cheddar
cheese or any kind of cheese you like in
there
um
cajun seasoning put a couple of
hard-boiled eggs in it yes yeah i like
that i like separately yeah i like
hard-boiled
if you get real fancy put some boiled
shrimp in there
zadaran's boiled shrimp it's been done
in
in cajun seasoning
that's what you want
crawfish boil
yeah that's something we haven't had in
a long time yeah
man the prices have been [ __ ] high
there was a time i could go to sam's and
get get those uh shrimp for what was
that 12 well sometimes they're on sale
yeah you gotta get 12.99 they go on sale
when a hurricane's coming
when a hurricane's coming out because
they're trying to get rid of all the
seafood because they're like well the
power is going to go out yeah everybody
buy all the meat yes everything goes up
so went down there and got like four big
old things so [ __ ] what was it
three or four i think there are three
pound bags of [ __ ] shrimp for like
i think it was like eleven dollars each
one
i think it was cheap i think it was
fifteen dollars five pounds and i think
it was 12.99 or 13.99 man i bought like
[ __ ] four bags yeah we got a bunch of
them we had [ __ ]
shrimp damn
lots of shrimp
and then every now and then you'll find
a sail on the crab legs
winn-dixie usually
yeah
so it's usually well the thing about
crab legs though is that
i love crab legs i love the king crab
legs but
you know it's like oh i'm getting like
10 pounds of crab legs but it's not
really 10 pounds because a lot of that
is all shell and you can't eat it yup
that's not 10 pounds of meat no
you know what i mean
so
uh
yeah
dermot says we don't have grits here in
the uk are they like polenta yeah yeah
they're very similar
pretty much the
whatever you can do with polenta you can
do with grits it's the same kind of
thing
um and german says how many
okay and somebody like well what's
harmony
you have to understand the south
corn
we had two different grades of corn
some corn
was particular was was uh bred to be
food corn
it's kind of softer kernels and you can
eat it right off the right off the cob
when it's cooked it's looking real good
other corn was more like cattle feed
um grade corn
you dried it they would dry those
kernels and crack them sometimes but it
was just a bunch of dried kernels you
could give it to cows or chickens or
pigs and they'll eat it
if you took
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
normal yeah it's just corn it's just
like corn just it's tough okay
if you cook it still it's tough
but you could take that stuff and you
could soften it up by putting it in a
big old barrel and put a lye in it yeah
and that lie would break that corn down
and chemically pop it just like popcorn
and it would go pop and it would pop and
you don't know if it made a noise
because it's happening in a barrel but
you find it like this we're imagining
it's making it like this wet popcorn
yeah
in the barrel and that's harmony you
could pull that out of there and put it
in a can or you could put it in a jar
and and seal it and it would keep
forever
and heat that up you can eat it like
that if you want to i never have my
grandma did but it's good old people
loved it yeah old people other
generations grew up on it so they liked
it it doesn't have a whole lot of flavor
that's surprising
well like i said it's kind of like rice
or something like that where you have to
like at it's like the base of something
you can't just eat it the way it is
because it's like doesn't taste like
anything now they eat they ate
harmony and things like that pre-civil
war
in the south [ __ ] forever all right
the civil war caused a lot of problems
in the economy a lot of survival [ __ ]
started to happen
and one of the things that they would do
is try to preserve
try to preserve harmony
so what you could do is you could take
hominy out of the [ __ ] vat and let it
dry
it would dry out
and once it was dry you could crumble it
into little bitty grits
and then you could re-cook it and
reconstitute it and it made like a
porridge like a polenta
and if you season it it's [ __ ]
beautiful it's better than harmony
i think
harmony doesn't have a big carrot i
guess
i could probably dress harmony up i
never really controlled the harmony
factor usually when i ate homie or
something your grandma gave you and she
yeah my grandmother was really she
always had like that how many in the
[ __ ] yeah old school can't hominy and
it wasn't really spiced it's just like
it's not bad it's just
there's not much like i said it doesn't
taste like anything yeah and they
overcooked the hell out of everything
back you know
our grandparents generation were [ __ ]
overcooked everything especially
vegetables they cooked everything down
to slime in the south i told you when i
was a kid i thought i hated vegetables
because everything was boiled to death
and didn't taste like anything spinach
was just and it wasn't seasoned yeah and
spinach they cooked spinach down to a
green slime
the first yeah it was just like the
first time i had raw spinach in a salad
my mind was blown yeah
because i'm like oh i thought spinach
was like gross and slimy and didn't yeah
anything and i don't know why they did
that it was
a food safety paranoia i believe
and uh they just thought everything
should be just cooked to death to make
sure it was safe to make yeah i think
it's what they were doing so they
basically cooked all the flavor
out of it and they weren't all the
texture and they weren't real big fans
of like seasoning stuff either no they
were they no not at all it was bland
so everything kind of tasted like
nothing
right which like i said for so for a
long time i thought that i didn't like
vegetables just because the way they had
been prepared like my whole childhood
but the south made a lot of things out
of corn
okay
corn
you know corn on the cob popcorn
uh cracked corn
hominy
[ __ ]
grits
and then uh cornmeal
and uh cornbread
lots and lots of corn stuff
like mexico mexico did the same thing we
just had a different way of dealing with
it
and uh
you can't get real cornbread outside of
the south
the deep deep south
i'm talking about mississippi alabama
parts of
central and northern
louisiana
maybe the panhandle florida panhandle
might know what real cornbread is real
cornbread is dry and coarse it's kind of
dense and dense heavy
and when you
bite it and chew it you'll feel that
you're you'll feel little things
cracking in there it'll crackle
because it's got like a grit in it
and it's just that cornmeal
all that light fluffy sweet cornbread
that's yankee [ __ ] [ __ ]
although i will still eat that too yeah
younger girl
it's good but um
but it's not sweet it's much sweeter
it's more like corn cake yeah and
real
old-school southerners laugh at that
[ __ ] they laugh at it they're like oh
that's not cornbread
real cornbread is
almost kind of like a
the closest thing to it
would be that mexicans have these
gorditas and they have this kind of like
a corn fritter like a cornbread that
they can make a gorgita out of they
slice it and then they'll put
their fillings in it i had it at that
real mexican restaurant over here it's
kind of like cornbread it's like a
tortilla that's risen slightly
well that's that's what they're eating
cornbread is even more risen a little
bit
but not much more
a mexican would really understand
cornbread they'd go oh okay yeah yeah
it would just be real familiar to them
that that flavor profile yeah and what
they're doing with it is you put butter
on it you can do that
people eat it with chili a lot i feel
like yeah
but chili is a texas thing yeah
um the thing that i mostly saw them
doing with mississippi is using it to
soak up
the
the drippings from or pot liquor and or
the drippings from collard greens yeah
that too okay yeah or brussels sprouts
yep
we had boiled brussels sprouts and it's
it's kind of spicy and it's served to
you in a in a bowl that has
drippings or water in the bottom of it
but it's like it's like vegetable
soup
or a vegetable gravy that's kind of come
out of it
and uh you're eating the collard greens
or whatever and you're taking the
cornbread and you're putting it down in
there and absorbing that moisture and
it's good it's good you have to know
what to do with it it's very southern
all that stuff should be in that
cookbook i think i gave it a real yeah
yeah in the cookbook that we sell and
you can go jenna will tell you where to
get it where do you get that cookbook
it's in the it's in the description it's
in the description
lulu.com just go to lulu.com and like
search 13 o'clock cookbook yeah lulu.com
sit and search for a 13 o'clock podcast
cookbook and it's in there
and it has it has a real cornbread
recipe
all right it's cheap to make it and you
just have to know what to eat it with uh
there's instructions for southern food
in there and brazilian food
and mexican food and italian yeah
asian food asian too all kinds of you
get some chinese stuff in there
and uh indian food indian food and it's
uh
be real handy for
people that live outside the south or
people that live in europe i got all the
instructions in there how to make that
stuff and where to source it
grant there's hammer said which is
better winn dixie or publix
down here publicly publix
uh wait what is good at certain things
it's good for certain southern stuff
southern stuff and
meat although yeah i don't know i kind
of feel like back when i was growing up
when dixie was kind of more known for
their meat because they had their own
you know uh
farms
but
i don't know about nowadays publix has
kind of a more urban flavor suburban
flavor to it uh there's a lot of cuban
style and latin style
food availability in there
um it's a little what you would call
higher on the hog
a little publix is a little higher end
generally it depends which
neighborhood you're in but when dixie is
like high-end
working class or middle class but
southern middle class that's where you
can go to get you could get okay you can
buy things in there that they wouldn't
sell in publix like you can get ham
hocks there
ham hocks
you could get
like the [ __ ] super southern [ __ ]
cuts because you need ham hocks what do
you need a ham hock for that's what you
make red beans and rice with well yeah
red beans and rice kind of like what
you'd get from popeyes you cannot
execute that recipe without ham hocks
you got to have them
um
smoked
oh
ham
hocks
bunch of different things that you can
get there real good better prices on
things like crab legs sometimes real
good sometimes shrimp it depends on what
it is they got a deli that's good stuff
like the boar's head is probably the
most expensive brand but they'll also
have more ethnic style
southern and soul food type stuff at
winn dixie
they'll have uh and be on the buffet you
know what i mean like you can go down
there
and get a bunch of
you know macaroni and cheese or it's
salad stuff or
uh what else is down there
i've seen them see that egg rolls i've
seen them have eggs it's like but
nowadays i kind of feel like when i was
growing up
um it was kind of like when dixie was
kind of like the working class yeah it
was ghetto and publix was kind of like
the yuppie place yeah yeah
um so you know what i mean but i kind of
feel like that distinction has vanished
well when disney updates up this game
well they had to yeah but it still has a
lot of those bargain brands and a lot of
those southern components that you need
but they've really like yeah like you
said they've really kind of like um
upped their i mean you know the
competition is so stiff nowadays it's
just kind of like we were talking about
before like fast food restaurants
even like the shittiest fast food
restaurant has to be at least decent
decent because you're going to go out of
business
because there's so many and it's so
competitive and people are so picky
nowadays yeah like food at 7 11 is
decent now it didn't used to be yeah
that's what i'm saying like back in the
old days you used to be like oh you're
eating like a taco from 7-eleven oh my
god you're going to get like [ __ ]
yeah some desserts it's just like
something microwaved out of the damn but
now it's like not
you know now it's like completely
acceptable yeah and there's like usually
like a subway or you can't get away with
[ __ ] like you used to which in a way
like that's good the worst fast food
restaurant that exists here
would be
um
hearties
isn't it hearties wasn't that hard no
what was that well at least we don't eat
a lot of fast food no but the worst fast
food circle k right was that a hearties
yeah yeah hearties
that those hamburgers are mediocre and
then still and but they're still edible
yeah they're still it's not like you ate
it and you were like oh god i'm gonna
like die now it was just kind of like
well that could have been better you eat
the burger and it's like
you can taste some soy in that patty
it's not
beef 100 beef it's got kind of like that
soybean burger [ __ ] texture to it and
it's just like
and
things are kind of strange but we've
eaten there [ __ ] in an emergency when
you're passing it man we're starving to
get somebody pull into hearties and
that's like the only drive-through like
for several miles and everything else is
okay like you know the [ __ ] fries and
the bun and
the the lettuce and the tomato that's
all that's it's just the patties the
meat is not
really not as good as mcdonald's not as
good as [ __ ] burger king
not as good as [ __ ] wendy's
wendy's has slipped over the years but
it's still okay still pretty good and
like i said i kind of feel like a lot of
it has to do with the location too
because some
locations that i've been to of like
wendy's or burger king were like way
better than others it's the same with
subway
some subways the bread is a lot better
than others and what that is is i had a
friend that worked there when he was a
kid he told me what why late the lazy
people are cooking the bread from
cooking the bread from frozen dough
but people that are on the game on the
ball are thong the dough out letting it
rise before they bake it which makes a
big difference in the texture of that
bread
but uh because i've had good subway and
bad subway
i kind of feel like subway even though
please correct me if i'm wrong but i'm
pretty sure subway is the most
ubiquitous
franchise at least in the united states
those [ __ ] are everywhere and
honestly even the circle k that we have
up at the end of our street has a subway
inside it used to be taco bell taco bell
used to be a [ __ ] there's still a lot of
taco bells yeah but i think i think
subway has the most locations yeah i
could be wrong about that but i'm pretty
sure i remember taco bell's being
everywhere and then long john silver's
being everywhere and you don't see long
john silversmith you know what it's
weird i kind of miss long john silver's
well there's not like really anywhere
you can go like fast food fish stuff
like i know like yes mcdonald's has a
fish sandwich yes burger king has a fish
sandwich but
it's not really we don't have anything
isn't there i guess not no
i mean every now and then i like a good
fish sandwich
might as well just go all the way and go
to red lobster or go to captain d's or
captain d's we do have captain d's
although didn't we do the numbers and
captain diesel ended up being about the
same prices red lobster for a couple
dollars more you can go to red dubsters
pretty much yeah
i think and you got about the same phone
i remember but [ __ ] captain d's is
definitely southern definitely oh yeah
you can get fried green tomatoes that's
[ __ ] southern as [ __ ]
we used to go there we had one that was
a probably about seven or eight miles
from our old house and it's pretty much
it's pretty much middle-aged black women
cooking it which is gonna be good it's
all deep fried yeah it's all deep-fried
and
because it's it's southern and it has a
[ __ ] ethnic flair to it they respect
that food
you can get uh yeah you get fried green
tomatoes you can get collard greens
get all kind of [ __ ] it's a chain but
yeah
yeah victor says is whataburger still in
florida i don't you know what i don't
know if we have any whataburgers around
here
i've never seen one i've lived in
florida my whole life and i've never
seen a water burner so i don't know
i don't know if it's one of those chains
that doesn't exist here or maybe it
exists in some parts of florida that
i've never been to
i've lived in central florida my whole
life and i've never seen one
um so i don't know
but
bee's nest said i can eat taco bell
every day i like taco bell actually i'm
not a big fan of taco bell to be honest
it's not mexican it's american well
obviously but there is
something there's something about it i
know everything about it i could just
eat 20 of them damn tacos
to sit there and just eat those if i'm
gonna get tacos i'd rather go to del
taco
and there's only like two of those in
orlando yeah so it's kind of they are
good but it's kind of a [ __ ] like to
get to
um i mean taco bells are everywhere yeah
but
i don't know i'm not every now and then
like i want fast food normally we'd go
to mcdonald's because it was the one
that was
on the way home
um
lately we've been going to burger king a
lot because that's on the way to the
movie theater
and i'm not a massive fan of burger king
although they it is better than it used
to be victor says uh what are burgers in
pensacola panhandle and jacksonville
okay so that's like that's way north of
us yeah
i don't think we have any in central
florida i've never seen one i'm not
saying they're not here i'm just saying
that i've never seen one
but
i'm honestly i used to really like
wendy's but
i mean i've been to a wendy's in a
really long time
i don't know they're not as common here
they have them but they're just not
everywhere
not here in florida what's here at what
is everywhere here is [ __ ]
circle k's seem to be everywhere
7-elevens are everywhere
mcdonald's seems to be pretty common and
so does hardys
you see a lot of those
and a lot of them are in gas stations
and like i said subways rural areas
subways and a lot of gas stations too
and to be honest with you it's kind of
like there's there's a situation now
where subways have kind of like taken
over the backs of gas stations that are
open all night so they're just
everywhere so they're all over the place
so i kind of feel like that's maybe how
they got to be like the most ubiquitous
fast food chain subways or um
parties
thank you victor go get some whataburger
we're gonna have to drive to [ __ ]
jacksonville yeah
that's pretty sweet that's pretty far
uh hugo says i like wendy's and in and
out yeah i always liked wendy's
um i've been in and out i don't think we
have any of those here i've been to when
i was a kid out in california when they
were good they were real good another a
good chain that california had that i
remember as a kid was carl's jr
back in the ear back in the 80s when i
was there that's owned by hardee's now
yeah so it's the same company
back in the day they were really good
and one of the best things that hardy's
had one of the best thing carl's jr has
had
back in the 80s was a damn burrito and
they had this burrito they would deep
fried all at once and then they would
give you some hot sauce and the sauce on
it was a [ __ ] great burrito
it was kind of like a all right kind of
like the burritos you get them in a
package at a gas station yes like that
but there's something about the filling
and the fact that they deep fried it
well deep frying makes everything better
yeah
it makes it like a thousand times more
unhealthy but it makes it taste like a
thousand dollars and they had another
one that back in the 70s and 80s
everyone's called jack-in-the-box that
used to be really good well until that
like e-coli breakout that they had it
was good
even after that now how that [ __ ] went
down in the 70s
mcdonald's refused to put
at a certain time just just wouldn't put
a restaurant in in an area that was uh
like a black area all right they
wouldn't do it because they were afraid
of [ __ ] just crime or whatever hiring
people
yeah standards of [ __ ] employee
standards and [ __ ] so they just were not
doing it back in the 70s so that left a
um a vacuum
in in black neighborhoods so the
jack-in-the-box would it was a
black-owned company
and [ __ ] jack-in-the-box was great
and that spread into what you would call
white areas
and it was good big old they had the
[ __ ] what was that thing called the
jumbo jack they used to [ __ ] love
those things
were big they had [ __ ] shredded
lettuce and tomatoes on them but they
had this thing hello oh rodney allen
rippy [ __ ] would do the commercials
you could see him on
i saw rodney allen and his mama and my
mom was weird at the pike and he was up
on the ferris wheel and he just looked
my mom because look there's right there
there's there's uh
like [ __ ] five and [ __ ] you know
we're the same age he ended up being an
entertainer evidently a little bit local
entertainer and when my mom and his mom
were talking and [ __ ]
he was telling him how good that how how
cute [ __ ] rodney allen was and the
[ __ ]
and the commercials and [ __ ] but anyway
um the uh it's funny funny i run into
those people but we were in the right
place the right time the right era and
[ __ ] the right [ __ ] scene i guess
but
um they had
one of the things that i really missed
about jack in the box was that they had
this taco
they [ __ ] sold a taco but check this
out
it was a folded taco with a corn
tortilla
with a filling that was like refried
beans mixed with meat it had lettuce and
tomato in it
and they folded it somehow to where it
kind of sealed
and they deep fried that
all right they were only like 50 cents
so you can get like five or five or six
of them for nothing
they were greasy and delicious and they
fried the lettuce right along with it
yeah the lettuce was fried in it
it was good though hot lettuce hot
lettuce it was just a cheap ghetto taco
that were [ __ ] and they give you this
[ __ ]
hot sauce just like right out of taco
bell you know cheap taco bell sauce it
was just like that yeah
but it was just like
the perfect [ __ ]
food you know what i mean they're like
it's just like you know like a cheap
food like you know like like i like the
[ __ ] just a regular mcdonald
hamburger nothing to it mcdonald's yeah
i eat like five or six of them sometimes
you don't want to gild the lily yeah
sometimes you just want like simple
simple simple simple [ __ ] maybe somebody
in the comment section remembers those
from the 70s and the 80s those [ __ ]
jag in the box tacos you guys you could
probably see hugo says they still have
those tacos they still have those
[ __ ] a man i miss those things
are they are they still good
i remember them being [ __ ] great
i loved them
um
i bet you i'd like to see an old 70s
commercial from them i'd probably be
able to smell them if i saw that damn
commercial you know i like your sense of
smell somehow it's really tending with
your memory yeah sometimes i'll see
something i remember as a kid and i'll
remember what it smells but it smells
like yeah and i'll smell that for a
second yeah yeah i have that too all
right like i said a lot of a lot of
people have that your sense of smell is
actually like much more powerful than
yeah but i love that big mac i love that
[ __ ] jumbo jack and those tacos i
[ __ ] remember this uh i don't
remember the fries so they must have
been kind of mediocre
i remember the onion rings though they
had good onion rings i remember the
onion rings being
kind of like uh
kind of like burger king onion rings you
guys said they still good they're still
good yeah
were they still cheap they made 50 cents
you can't [ __ ] up a deep fried top deep
fried taco
lettuce deep fried into it and
everything i mean that would be really
hard to mess that up
let me ask you this hugo i remember that
the taco kind of folded in on itself and
that it sealed i don't think the top of
the taco was open was it so it was
essentially like an egg roll like a hot
pocket or a hot pocket yeah you take a
[ __ ] tortilla and [ __ ] seal it
like a hot pocket yeah like an egg roll
or a hot pocket exactly
that's how i remembered it it might have
been open on top but i don't think it
was because
it had lettuce in it
and i would be eating them and like
adults would look at it and he goes man
they fried the lettuce that's terrible
why would they do that like hotline i'm
just like
[ __ ] good yeah
it's just something that worked i mean
you know this worked kind of like a
white castle burger that [ __ ]
that shouldn't taste good but it kind of
has its own flavor and yeah and if you
like that then we don't have white
castle here we had crystal which is
pretty much the same it's the same thing
uh victor says jack has good curly fries
and potato wedges do they okay i don't
remember curly fries or i wish that more
fast food places would do wedges yeah i
kind of feel like kfc did them for a
little while because i remember i don't
go to kfc a lot but i remember like back
in the old days they used to have potato
wedges and i was kind of like thank you
somebody
likes these big like chunk because i
like big chunks of potato man with like
skin on it now the thing with jack on
the box that i remember when i was a kid
this must be in the 70s maybe somebody
could actually get the date if you go
hit through if you hit google
i remember the [ __ ] i was a kid
it was in the 70s sometime maybe late
70s it might have been early 80s but
late 70s i think
it was all over the news that
jack-in-the-box was being sued because
they claimed that it was a hundred
percent all beef patty
and it wasn't it was wallaby
that's bad
what's that that's no it was wallaby
do you know how expensive wallaby meat
would be not back in those days
they got a big shipment of [ __ ]
wallaby i don't buy it and
it was true it was true and then i
remember they had a whole pr campaign
saying well it wasn't all while it
wasn't all wallaby they cut it with some
wall of it
there was a little bit of wallop in
there and i'm just saying how that was a
high quality meat and that it was that
it was that look meats made okay yeah it
wasn't it's not human calm down
it was wallaby or kangaroo but it was
they got it from australia and it was
like some kind of farm i think wallaby
if i remember you guys can google that
[ __ ] we're all we're live i can't google
it you google it it was [ __ ] wild
people if i remember correctly
and uh i remember him saying that
and like there was other people at the
time going yeah well
what would you rather have would i have
it cut with soybean or would you